In the last 12 months, my social media
had a grand total of 3 billion
impressions and brought in 4 and 1/2
million new subscribers. And with that,
I managed to break the world record for
the fastest-selling non-fiction book of
all time, generating just over 105
million dollars in sales in a weekend.
And here are my top lessons that I've
learned when it comes to building a
personal brand. Enjoy.
You guys want to hear something
absolutely insane? I was able to take
home more in a year than the CEOs of
McDonald's, IKEA, Ford, Motorola,
and Yahoo
combined
as a kid in his 20s.
And I have continued to for over half a
decade.
Which resulted in a 200 million-dollar
per year portfolio and a 100
million-dollar net worth by age 32.
And no one is more surprised than me.
Me expressing that fact will create envy
in some,
anger in others, skepticism in most,
confusion in old people,
and inspire a select few.
You are who I made this presentation
for.
But before I dive in,
raise your hand if you'd like any of the
following things to happen.
To be able to charge two times, five
times, 10 times more than your
competition for the exact same thing,
like Yeti. We have basically identical
cups, and somehow they're able to charge
$40 versus $10 simply because of what's
on the cup.
If you'd like to be able to have
customers buy from you over and over and
over again without considering
competition, like Harley. Once you're a
Harley guy, you stay a Harley guy for
life.
And if you'd like to virtually guarantee
sales in any new business or product
that you launch, like Apple. A lot of
people just wait in line. They say,
"Just leave my credit card. Just bill me
and send whatever you're going to come
out with." And that's more or less how a
lot of Apple buyers are. Once they
become an Apple person, they become an
Apple person for life.
So, if you like that stuff,
great, cuz that's what this talk is
about.
And so, I couldn't figure out how these
brands, these companies were able to do
this, demand these prices, get people to
stay loyal for a really long time.
And
I felt like for me, I always had to like
beg, borrow, and steal, and I just
squeeze and push so hard just to get
people to buy.
Whereas these companies made it look
effortless.
And it's because I didn't understand
this one thing, and that's the subject
of the talk today.
Brand.
And the thing is, even people who claim
to understand it often don't.
And the few who do understand it do a
terrible job teaching it.
So, this definitely isn't going to be
marketing 101 class on branding
presentation colors and logos.
And this definitely isn't going to be
about feelings, presence, intuition, or
whatever.
This is about making money.
And this concept that I'm going to
explain to you is how I built a 7.8
million person audience across all these
platforms
in the past 40 months or so. I sold over
a million copies of my last two books.
And your deals worth hundreds of million
dollars in our holding company
acquisition.com.
That is why you build a brand. At least,
that's why I built mine.
And so today I'm going to cover three
things.
Number one, what branding is.
You don't know what it is, you certainly
can't build one. Number two, why it
makes money. Cuz once you have it built,
you're like, okay, well, how do I trade
this thing for doll hairs, which is what
we want.
And then third, how to start and grow
yours.
So, let's start with the first one. What
branding is.
So, when I decided to build a brand, I
looked at what many popular marketers
said about it.
Here are some popular definitions that I
have removed the marketers from them.
This is not throwing shade. So, I'm just
saying them.
A brand is a person's gut feeling about
a product, service, or organization. A
brand is not what you say it is, it's
what they say it is. A brand is a set of
expectations, memories, stories, and
relations to that taken together account
for a customer's decision to choose one
product or service over another.
A brand is emotional shorthand for
accumulated and assumed information. A
brand is present when the value of what
the product, service, or personality
means to its audience is greater than
what it does for the audience.
A brand is a product, service, or
concept that is publicly distinguished
from other products, services, or
concepts so they can be easily
communicated and usually marketed.
Branding is the process of creating and
disseminating the brand name, its
qualities, and personality.
The promotion of a particular product or
company by means of advertising and
distinctive design.
If these sound vague and confusing, it's
because
they are.
And I was just as confused as you when I
was trying to figure this out.
Because none of them told me what to do.
And so after looking at all these
marketers' words, I think I pieced it
together.
At least enough that once I started
thinking about this way, in a different
way that I'm going to share with you, my
brand grew and it grew fast.
And the reason this is so important is
that if you don't know what to do,
nothing's going to change.
Fundamentally, if you don't change your
behavior, obviously nothing's going to
change as a result. And so I wanted to
define this one term before we get
going.
Learn it.
Who here came to learn?
Raise your hands. Fantastic. All right,
the other ones just be talking to the
wall.
So, learning means same condition, new
behavior.
And so if I wanted to teach someone a
phone script,
then after teaching you, the phone rings
again,
and you say the new script,
you learned. Learning occurred.
On the other hand,
if I tried to teach you the script, and
then the phone rings again,
and then you change nothing,
no learning occurred. You learned
nothing.
And that's why none of this stuff that
these guys said helped me, because I
didn't know what I could do. I didn't
know what behavior I had to change as a
result of this.
So I didn't know how to do that.
And so here's how branding happens.
Branding is a deliberate pairing of
things
through an outcome. So I'll say that
again. Branding is a deliberate pairing
of things through an outcome.
So, let's use Coca-Cola, drinking it,
and liking it as our example.
The yum, aka the outcome, that's what
people get.
They pair that with drinking, the action
that they do to get it,
with Coca-Cola, the product.
So, the next time you want some yum,
you're probably going to reach for
a Coca-Cola, if that was paired for you
successfully.
And so, branding is delivering pairing
of things through an outcome. That's it.
But, sometimes businesses pair stuff,
pair their stuff with things that people
don't like.
That's bad branding.
This leads to losses for the business.
Now, some of you guys may have seen
this. This is Dylan Mulvaney doing a
collaboration with Bud Light.
There's a lot of press around this
advertisement.
This advertisement was actually a great
advertisement. And you might might think
I'm crazy, but it was. Let me explain.
It's just not the way you might think it
was.
This is a great advertisement because it
let a lot of people know about their
stuff.
It let a lot of people know about the
product, about Bud Light.
By the way, if you're curious, that is
the definition of advertising, not
branding. Advertising is letting people
know about your stuff. Branding is the
pairing that occurs as a result.
So, it was good advertising, but bad
branding.
Many customers hated this pairing. Lots
of people found out, but a lot of people
hated it. Good advertising, bad
branding.
And so, as a result of this bad
branding, people not liking the pairing,
fewer people bought the product,
which netted a loss for the business.
And so, to fix this,
Bud Light paired their product with
stuff the audience liked,
like Shane Gillis, who is a man's man
comedian, and the UFC, a man's man of
sports, if you will.
And sales began to recover.
So, that's the 101 explanation of
branding.
Let's go into 201.
So, we're going a little deeper because
the better you get at this, the more
money you will make. Like the more
nuance you can understand how to brand
and build a brand for yourself, the more
money you will make. I promise you that.
And so, to some people, the Dylan
Mulvaney pairing was actually good. In
general, both good advertising and good
branding.
Hear me out.
For others, it was bad, obviously.
All pairings have positive and negative
results, and that's because everyone's
different. Everyone has different
preferences.
But for a business, you can objectively
see if a pairing was good or bad whether
it netted you more money.
So,
more people disliked the Dylan Mulvaney
Mulch
tough day Dylan Mulvaney pairing, so the
sales suffered, making it a bad pairing.
So, this isn't opinion. They objectively
made less money, and so this pairing was
a bad one
for their ideal audience. Now, the 301
version of this is is there a company or
a product where the Dylan Mulvaney
pairing could have been both good
advertising and good branding so that
the majority of people would have bought
it. I think the answer is yes.
It just doesn't necessarily mean it's
Bud Light for conservative males as the
primary audience.
And on the other hand, some people love
the new Gillis and UFC pairings,
and some hated it.
But more of the audience that is their
ideal customer liked it, saw it as good,
and so the business netted sales a
result, and they made more money.
Good branding.
And so, for Budweiser, and I just want
to call this out, this is specifically
for Budweiser and their customer base.
It's not that Shin Gillis and the UFC is
magic in some way, or Dylan Mulvaney is
unmagic in some way, but for that
specific audience, yes, the pairing
mattered and how much of the base liked
it or disliked it.
So, if you're anything like me,
making money is the point.
So, let's drive this home.
If you made a pairing of your thing and
your customer,
and you got to choose which outcome you
had happen, so you have your product and
they drink it.
There's an outcome that happens
afterwards, right? That pairs with it.
On one hand, 75% like it and 25 hate it.
Or on the other hand, 25% like it and
75% hate it, which would be the bottom
example.
Which would you choose?
More money good, the big the big green
one. Yes, of course.
The top one.
Because it would make you the most
money.
And so, to be clear for the 201 level of
understanding,
branding always happens.
Branding always occurs.
But our goal is good branding.
And good branding is a deliberate
pairing of our business with good
outcomes for our ideal customers.
And so, what you pair your business with
determines two key things. One, who pays
attention to your business,
and two, whether they go towards your
business, like the UFC example,
or away from your business, like the
Dylan Mulvaney example.
And so, at the beginning of this I said
I was going to cover three things. The
first thing I said is what is branding.
But now that we have gone through that,
I want to re-say what I
walked us through, which is what good
branding is.
Ideally, what we're shooting for.
So, now that we covered that, let's talk
about why it makes you money. Why good
branding makes you money.
Branding as I define it happens
everywhere all the time.
But businesses use it for profit. So,
let's look at some of the earliest uses
of branding to figure out how we can use
it. So, these are the first
entrepreneurs who used branding to make
money. Real quick, I'm going to show you
the exact 10-stage roadmap from zero to
100 million plus that less than 1% of
companies finish I've now done multiple
times, and so I can say with a lot of
confidence that these are the stages, as
head count increases, that you need to
get through. And I broke each of these
down by eight different functions of the
business, what the constraint feels
like, like what are the symptoms of it
when you're going through it, and then
what steps we actually took to graduate.
And we've done this across software,
physical products, service businesses,
brick and mortar, all of this, and it
works. And it's my gift to you, it's
absolutely free. And so the link's in
the description, but you just go
acquisition.com/roadmap,
just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you, all free.
The earliest version of branding that we
can think of, or at least that I can
think of,
happened on livestock. It was literally
a brand. They'd heat up metal, they'd
sear it into the side of a cattle, and
they would get a lovely little logo.
Maybe we'll have a Nike swoosh cow
someday.
And so they literally burned these
symbols into animals.
And those symbols had a magical effect.
So let's say you're walking around and
you see a cow with no brand. You say,
"Hello cow." The cow says moo back, and
it has nothing on it. This is just a
cow.
You might leave it alone,
and that might be it.
On the other hand, let's say the cow has
a brand you recognize. Say it's your
neighbor's. You might be like, "Hey,
that's Bill's cow."
Now,
if you like Bill,
you might grab the cow and pull him by
the whatever you pull cows by,
and probably return it to Bill.
If you hate Bill, then the cow may stay
lost in the wilderness forever and
become lunch for your family for the
next month or two in the form of
delicious burgers.
Moo.
But either way,
for better
or for worse,
the brand affected what you did. It
affected your behavior.
And so to take this to the 201 level,
what if you see a branded cow, but you
don't recognize the brand? You might be
like, "Who this? I see a logo,
but I don't know anything about it."
Well, then you would treat it how you
treat branded animals in general in that
you just know that it belongs to
someone. And so you would treat it the
way that you would treat it as though it
belonged to anybody else.
And even if only a tiny bit, you would
treat a wild cow different from a
branded cow in general.
So if you had one that was wild and you
had one that you didn't recognize but
was branded, you would still probably
treat them differently. So that just
shows you the power of brand as a
concept because it dictates a tie
between that cow and a human being.
Or some complex animal that can brand
cows.
And so these are all effects of brand in
general.
So that's how it affects what people do.
And so now I want to get tactical on how
to get how we translate that concept
into getting them to buy.
So let's say we pair our brand. So this
is where we get really tactical and this
is like, okay, if you don't have a
brand, this is the step-by-step right
now.
So you have a weak brand and we say it's
a weak brand cuz it's starting out. You
don't have really a lot of associations.
Fantastic.
So now you want to pair it with people,
experiences, other
other stuff that your ideal customer
likes. So in this instance, I'm using
little Nike pairing with LeBron and
Tiger who are champions, world-class,
goats, etc. And so people who like
sports and competition would see that
probably as a positive pairing.
AKA good stuff.
And so if we do that pairing or we make
that pairing
for the majority of people, branding
will occur and so the brand grows.
And so the question then follows, what's
the benefit of a strong brand versus a
weak brand?
And so the the the weak brand is before
the pairing, the stronger brand is after
the pairing.
So a strong brand turns commoditized
products like a $5 white t-shirt
plus the strong brand
into a premium product, a higher value
brand name product.
And premium products with a strong brand
then get customers to want to pair
themselves with the product
so that they can associate the outcome
themselves with the outcome the brand
delivers.
Which they do with their money. So, how
do they make that association? They give
money, they get the shirt, the
association happens based on what
they've seen where that logo has been
elsewhere.
And so then they go from I want to be a
winner to exchanging money and saying
now I am a winner or I feel like a
winner.
That's how this works.
And so this means that if the ideal
customer likes sports, winning, and
competition, etc. then they're more
likely to buy stuff from a brand paired
with those things.
So, let's lay it all out.
Weak brand
paired with stuff customers like
creates a strong brand. Strong brand
gets put onto a winning product,
transforms a generic to winning product.
Then the customers want
to associate with that winning product,
so they buy the product, and they put
money into your bank account in order to
do it. And so as long as you net a
positive between what it cost you to
associate with Tiger and LeBron
and how many t-shirts you can sell as a
result, you make money.
And so here are some steps in words for
those of you who are more word people.
You start with a brand that means
nothing. You have a logo, just like the
cow that the other person didn't
recognize. People know that it is a
brand, they just don't know what that
brand means yet. So, it means nothing
right now.
Then you pair that brand with something
or someone that your customer is ideally
like.
Third, your brand starts to mean the
thing customer likes to them.
Then they want to associate themselves
with that thing they like or get more of
it.
But they can't buy that thing.
But they can buy a tiny sliver of that
association.
So, they buy the shirt with the logo
that means that thing to them.
And so they get the shirt, you get the
money, and it all happened because you
deliberately paired it with something
they like.
And this happens everywhere. So, Dolce &
Gabbana, classic example. They paired
with Kim Kardashian. They made a line
specifically for her.
And so, for a lady who wants to
associate with fame,
beauty,
wealth,
that would be a pairing that makes
sense. And so, that lady who wants other
people to associate her with fame, high
class, money, luxury, wealth, will then
buy Dolce & Gabbana and be like, "I'm
just like Kim." Now, she might not say
that directly because she might just
associate with the values, but the
transference still happens.
And so, when someone looks at two
products that on the surface are
generically the same. You've got two
t-shirts. One that has a weak brand or
no brand, and the other that has the
strong brand,
the person that has the strong brand,
they're going to be more likely to buy
and pay more for.
And this happens because they actually
buy the elements that we've deliberately
paired with the brand which they
identify with.
And at this point of building a brand,
you do this to change customer behavior.
And that excuse me, that is the point of
building a brand, to change customer
behavior in your favor
when they see it with a product.
And so, this is a quote from Warren
Buffett that I like a lot, kind of
signifying some of the elements of the
benefits of brand. He said, "The single
most important decision in evaluating
business is pricing power. If you've got
the power to raise prices without losing
business to a competitor, you've got a
very good business.
And if you have to have a prayer session
before raising the price by 10%, then
you've got a terrible business." And so,
if we have an unbranded t-shirt for $5,
and we say, "You know what? We think we
have a strong enough brand that we can
raise the price." And then, boom, we can
raise the price and still not lose that
many sales, but we
in this case, 12x the price, good
branding drives that premium pricing.
Good branding also
improves advertising. So, with the
generic brand, if you're marketing this
white t-shirt, you might get half a
percent of people. There are many white
t-shirts.
There are many like it. This one is
mine. Just kidding. So, the point of
those of you got the reference. Um so,
if you have a 0.5% click-through rate on
something that's generic, there's
nothing special about it. On the flip
side, if you have a Nike brand t-shirt,
same identical t-shirt, and it has the
swoosh, then you might get six times as
many people click
and buy at a higher price. See how these
things stack together? That is why these
brands exist for such a long period of
time and make so much money.
So, they get cheaper customers, they get
higher returns, and they have better
response rates in advertising.
And on top of that, if if as if that
weren't enough, good branding also
drives customer loyalty. AKA, they buy
more stuff more times. And so, like the
Apple example I gave earlier, once you
buy one Apple product, you tend to buy
more, and you tend to keep buying them.
And so, this also, a good brand, also
protects your business from competitors
stealing that customer for in the
future.
And so, as I promised at the beginning,
we're seeing how this all this stuff
allows you to one, be able to charge 10
times or more than your competition,
two, get higher returns in advertising,
so you can scale that much more, that
much faster, and then three, get people
to keep buying for life, compounding
your money-making skills for good.
Okay.
Which is why I'm building a brand will
make you lots of money.
It's also why brands outperform
commodities in every single industry.
And give a lasting competitive edge
that to be fair is theirs to lose. So,
here's another quote from Uncle Warren.
It takes 20 years to build a reputation
and 5 minutes to ruin it. If you think
about that, you'll do things
differently.
And so, I said that I was going to cover
three things. One, what branding is,
which we read into what good branding
is. Second, why it makes you money, and
we got that. So, now, let's go to how to
start or grow your own brand.
So, if is the deliberate pairing of
things, your thing plus what your ideal
customer has, through an outcome,
and good branding is the deliberate
pairing of your thing with something
good,
to start a brand,
we have to know what we want to pair it
with to attract ideal customers.
So, here we've got Bud Light, UFC, good
outcome for the majority of the
audience.
And we want to understand that just as
much as we should also understand what
to avoid pairing our brand with to lose
customers, like the Del Monte example.
And so, here's how I like to think about
assembling the pairings for a brand. So,
if you're at ground zero, you have you
have no brand. You've got these elements
that haven't been put together yet.
So, I think about it like
a tableful of flowers.
So, if you want to put a bouquet
together, you start by having lots of
different flowers all over the place.
On their own, those flowers are not a
bouquet.
Just as products, values, experiences,
people, etc. on their own are not a
brand.
The flowers are like the brand elements
that we pair with stuff our audiences
like.
With enough pairing, over and over and
over again, they form a bouquet.
Now, replace the word bouquet with
brand.
And so, that assembly is the connection,
it's the association between those
things. Cuz a brand, fundamentally,
doesn't actually exist. If I take the
flowers out of the vase and scatter them
across, was there ever a brand to begin
with? It's simply the association we
make between those things that creates
the one-of-one brand.
And if we unravel it, the brand
disappears.
And so, the deliberate pairing of those
things makes the brand.
And if we want to get narrower on our
brand, so let's say I talk about tacos,
lifting, and philosophy,
if I want to narrow my brand, I'll just
talk a bunch about tacos, and then all
of my flowers are just taco-related.
If I'm only talking about tacos, but I
want to expand the stuff I'm talking
about to my audience and maybe capture a
wider audience, then I might talk about
tacos, quesadillas, burritos, things
that are tangential. And then if I
wanted to expand even broader, I might
just talk about food in general. And
then I might talk in alcohol, then I
might talk in restaurants, and then
things that go
wider and wider from there. And so we
get narrower as we niche down and we go
double down on one type of topic and we
go broader when we branch out.
But
distant and random pairings hurt a brand
because they're so hard to make the
associations with.
And this is what most brands are and do.
Most people's brands happen by accident.
It's just whatever they appear next to,
whatever the people associate their
stuff with.
Good branding happens on purpose.
Cuz like what are we looking at with a a
bike, a single flower, some socks, and a
burger?
Not a lot. Not a lot to hold together
there.
And so think about it like curating a
garden. You want some flowers to grow
and you want to pull out the weeds. You
have to do both. You have to add the
good and take away the bad in order to
assemble the ideal brand for you.
And in the beginning, our brand won't be
strong, just like yours won't. If you're
building it, then you might only have a
couple flowers there. It's because you
haven't had that many instances to pair
your brand for that customer.
But the more good stuff we pair with our
brand for the customer, the stronger it
gets. You go from one flower to many red
flowers or many red roses that become a
bouquet of red roses. That's what you're
about, and the more you're about it, the
more the brand strengthens.
Now, what if we make a branding mistake
and pair with the wrong thing? Cuz it's
going to happen.
One bad pairing can absolutely hurt a
brand. So if I now give my this lovely
red rose a bouquet to my wife and I say,
"Hey,
don't you love this bouquet?" And she
sees this rotten flower sitting out in
the front. She might be like, "Ew, this
bouquet sucks." Or, "This brand sucks."
Or, "Hey, that guy got a DUI and I
thought he was this paragon of good
ethics."
Well, that would hurt the brand.
And so, just like one ugly flower messes
up the whole bouquet,
it changes how everyone sees the brand.
This bouquet sucks.
Now, to recover from something like
that,
you just have to overwhelm customers
with the stuff they like until
eventually the bad pairing shrinks into
irrelevance. So, we don't try to
eliminate the DUI, we don't try to
eliminate the dead rose. It happened,
there's nothing we can do about it.
But, what we try to do is just overwhelm
it with way more of the stuff that the
majority of our people actually like.
And so, Kanye, for example, has said
some things that people don't like.
But, he also comes out with products
that people love. He made a Super Bowl
ad.
He sold shoes. He just came out with an
album that came out after having some
cancel culture stuff around him, things
he had said.
And so, over time, people forgot the bad
stuff and associated the good stuff back
with him and purchased.
They still bought.
And so, you need to decide what values
people experience, etc., that you want
to use to connect the audience to your
product.
And equally importantly, what things you
want to avoid, remove, or ignore from
the stuff they hate.
And so, it goes without saying that even
if you say you're premium, but people
think your thing sucks, that suck will
stick. And so, up to this point,
everything I've talked about has been
the things external to the product.
They've been the people you associate
the product with. You know, almost all
of that occurs prior to purchase. So,
you can absolutely get someone to buy
the thing.
But, how many experiences are people
going to have with the thing once
they've purchased it? Probably far more
than they have with your advertisement.
And so the advertisement can let people
know about it. The branding makes a good
association with the person. They make
the purchase. And then afterwards, the
product does a lot of the branding after
that. Cuz if I buy that amazing Nike
t-shirt, and there's a hole in the
armpit when it comes in, I might say, if
this is the first time I've ever bought
a Nike product, this product sucks.
Therefore, Nike sucks. And then I think
the whole thing is a sham. And then I
also start to hate LeBron for even
recommending it. Right? So it starts to
transfer backwards.
Now, on the flip side,
brand can influence how people see the
product. So if the product is what I
would call good enough, so it's it
doesn't have any holes in it. Now, is it
the highest quality it possibly could
be? Maybe not, but it's good enough that
no one's going to find an immediate
problem with the product.
That's where brand can carry you the
extra distance to still make it a
positive experience for the person. And
so brand, in a very real way, can affect
how people perceive value through
products.
Now, me personally, it's a pro tip here.
If I'm going to charge a premium price,
I absolutely want to make sure that the
product is dialed, so that I only
further reinforce how much they like my
brand, rather than
let my brand carry me, or at worst, have
it conflict with the impression that I
gave them of the thing they were going
to buy prior to them buying it. This is
a quote from Warren. Your premium brand
had better be delivering something
special, or it's not going to get the
business. And the only tweak I'd have on
this is that it's not going to keep the
business.
You'll get the first purchase, you just
won't get the ones after that.
And so all these things you're like,
okay, got it. So brand is pairing. I get
how the pairing makes me money. I have
these big margins. I got more CTRs. More
people buy. And as long as my thing
doesn't suck, you know, ideally that
it's good, people will keep buying.
Awesome.
But how do I measure that?
So brand has three main metrics.
One, which is influence, which is how
likely it is to change someone's
behavior.
So, if I show someone a brand and they
react in any way, they recognize it and
they they they do something about it,
then we have influence.
Second is direction.
Are they changing the way we want it?
Were they running away?
And third, how many people it changes
for.
That's it. So, if I show it to 100
people and 100 people react versus two
people react, the 100 person reacting at
least recognition, that is the reach.
How many people it changes it for.
So, taking to the hypothetical extreme,
a small, weak, and neutral brand, very
few people recognize, and the people
that do don't care that much about it
either way.
And on the other polar extreme, you have
a large, large, strong, positive brand.
So, that would be lots of people
recognize the brand, it changes the
behavior when they see the brand, and
the behavior is generally towards. So,
they try to do in accordance with what
that brand is asking someone to do.
And I want to make this point.
A lot of people have this misnomer that
any strong brand is polar. That because
lots of people love it, lots of people
also have to hate it. Now, I say this by
percentage, not necessarily by absolute.
If you have If the whole United States
knows who you are, you're going to have
a percentage of people that hate you
just cuz there's crazy people. And
that's not what we're talking about. I'm
saying, is there a brand that can't have
that kind of status that isn't polar?
So, I'll give a polar example first. So,
I have the silhouette of Donald Trump
here, and he has a very strong brand.
He has a big reach, lots of people
recognize him, even just a silhouette
alone people recognize.
He has strong influence as in
the percentage of people that when they
see this have a reaction in either
direction, positive or negative, but
just that they react shows that he has
strong influence.
And the third is the direction. Now, for
him, he is polar, meaning many people
move towards him very strongly, and many
people move away from him very strongly.
And so, many assume that all brands are
that way. And that's just because there
are many examples of that, but it
doesn't mean it has to be that way.
And so, I'll give you a different
example.
So, some brands manage to change many
people's behavior towards them all at
once. And so, like Taylor Swift, sure,
I'm sure she's got some crazies, don't
get me wrong. But the vast majority of
people who see Taylor Swift recognize
her,
she changed their behavior and most of
the time it's towards her. So, she is a
large, positive, strong brand.
This is also personally why I think the
idea of like seeking out controversy
absolutely gets you recognized,
but you don't have to make that trade.
You can absolutely just build a strong
positive brand. Mother Teresa has a
strong positive brand. A lot of people
know her, influence a lot of behavior,
did a lot of good stuff. Most people
aren't like, "I hate Mother Teresa."
Some people do,
but most people don't. And the same
thing goes with Apple.
A lot of people like their products. I'm
sure there are some tech geeks that are
like, "Android's way better." Or they're
like, "PCs are awesome." And that's
great, that's good for them. But the
vast majority of people who encounter
the product like it, which is why
they're one of the largest companies in
the world.
So, all those examples that I gave to
you up to this point have assumed a
large audience. And I do that because
this is a presentation and it makes more
sense for me to work with you on stuff
that you already know.
But this concept carries independent of
whether you have large reach, and this
is why it applies to you.
So, if you had a small audience with
high influence, what would you have?
Your mom and dad.
They are high influence, as in most
people when they see their parents,
their behavior changes.
They have low reach
cuz for you, they're only your parents.
They might not be any other people's
They might be some other people's
parents, but not many very many people's
parents.
Also, you have low reach.
Um and it will be your behavior will
towards for some and away for others.
Meaning, some people hate their parents
and don't want to do anything they say,
and some people like their parents to do
whatever they say. And there's a lot of
people in between.
And so that's how we measure if what
we're doing to grow our brand is
actually working. Are more people
finding out about it?
Are more people changing their behavior
when they do it? And ideally, are they
doing that towards the direction that we
want them to go? So if I say, "Hey
everybody, go click here, go download
this thing, go attend this event, go buy
this product, whatever it is."
If a lot of people do that,
then we know that the brand is growing.
And so we want when we want to build our
brand, we want to pair ourselves with
the things the highest percentage of our
ideal audience like.
And so whenever we pair anything with a
brand,
because especially if you're starting
out, everything is new.
And so every new pairing has risk.
And so you risk losing a certain
percentage of your audience who has a
bad experience with the thing you pair.
There's always that risk. There's always
going to be some people who don't like
something you do.
If anyone's seen a small town band go
hit it big,
some of the old towners are like, "Oh,
they sold out. They did whatever." But
what they did was they gambled the
short-term loss of that local audience,
potentially, for a much broader, bigger
audience. So they made a bet. They did
lose people. They did gain people. They
just gained more than they lost.
And so to the same degree, when you make
that bet as the local band, you risk
gaining other people who have had a
positive experience with this new thing.
And ideally, we have more green than
red.
And so those new pairings, the new
pairings you make with a brand, always
lose audience, right? He sold out. I
like the old stuff better. This also
happens with content, by the way.
And so this person is the red bucket.
Fantastic.
And the new stuff might also cause
people to say, "No, this new stuff
rocks." And that person is in the green
bucket.
And so whenever you try to grow and you
make any new pairing, meaning you make
new content, you make a new genre, you
don't make a new song, you make a new
anything,
you make a bet
that more people from your ideal
audience will like the pairing than
people who don't.
TLDR,
that you'll net an increase in reach,
influence, and positive direction.
And so, my ask for everyone here is
don't let the five mean comments stop
you from gaining the 500 new people who
like the new thing.
So, let me finish the real-life example
to make this whole thing real for you.
I want to associate myself with business
value.
So, I associate myself with making
people money and growing their
businesses. So, there's me, there's me
making content, and then ideally money.
And so, the best way I can do this is
make content for the small business
owner kids to consume and books for them
to read and use, so that they then
profit.
The good thing.
And then they associate that growth
and profit with me.
And so, then they consume more of my
stuff.
They drink the next soda.
They buy the next shirt.
And so, the next time they wanted to
happen again, they take the action or
they have a higher likelihood of taking
the desired action.
And equally important, people who don't
like business stuff won't like my stuff
or they'll just prefer to watch other
things. So, you've got this married
couple, they say, "We hate people who
talk about money." They're probably not
going to like my stuff.
And that's okay.
But,
people who
like business,
have a business, or are trying to start
one, might want more.
And this grows the bread because people
consume the stuff and they say, "Hey,
you got to check out Herazi's stuff."
And then that person they tell to who
says, "Right on." They check it out.
They get that positive outcome. They
make the pairing as well and the brand
grows. And ideally, with my ideal
audience.
And so, to see this in action, if you
use this information from today to make
money,
good branding has occurred.
And so, I said I was going to cover
three things: what branding is, ideally
what good branding is, why it makes you
money, and how to start and grow yours.
So, hopefully you feel like I've
fulfilled those three things.
And so, now we can test if the pairing,
good breeding, actually occurred.
So, if you are my ideal customer, so
here's a business owner.
Okay, awesome. Lottie, pay attention.
We can see objectively if this provided
value. Did we get a good positive
outcome, a neutral outcome, or a
negative one? You might be like, I hate
this guy talking about money, or you
know what, I think this could make me a
ton of money. Well, we'll see.
So, I want you further to associate
myself with value in making you money
and growing your business. So, I'm going
to give you guys two gifts for free.
The first is for existing business
owners who want to scale. So, most of
you guys have raised your hands.
I have two books, $100 Million Offers,
$100 Million Leads.
People say they made them money. There's
a lot of five-star reviews on them.
Fantastic.
And I mean video versions of these books
that you can get absolutely free on my
site at acquisition.com/training.
This is me further associating. If you
If you like this, you're going to love
that.
And they'll make you more money for
free.
That's what it looks like on the inside.
These are legit courses.
And you can get those video versions on
my site, again, absolutely free,
acquisition.com/training.
Now,
if you're like, man, I don't like
watching stuff, I like listening to
stuff.
I want to provide value for a different
type of ideal audience, which is still
business owners, but business owners who
listen rather than business owners who
watch, which is also fine. And so if you
are somebody who's not a reader or not a
watcher, I've got the books on my
podcast
absolutely free.
It's called The Game. They started
episode
570 something. And so that's what I have
for business owners.
Who here is earlier on and they're like,
I want to start a brand?
Okay, cool.
So, this is for you.
So, I did become an owner school.com,
really awesome platform, helps people
get started in the business.
Um and so anybody here who watches this
or listening to this and wants the
tools,
the training, and a community of other
people starting brands with a little
friendly competition and some prizes,
we made a step-by-step process on school
to help you get started. And you can
start for free.
So hopefully I succeeded in providing
value and a good pairing occurred,
ideally good branding happened,
otherwise I'm sorry. For everybody else,
I hope good branding occurred. Um and
for those of you who either start the
school games for free or use my stuff to
grow your business, I will see you guys
soon. So go to school games,
school.com/games,
acquisitions.com/training and I'll see
you guys all there. Thank you guys so
much for your time. So next I want to
talk about how I got 7.8 million
followers in just 3 months and the six
key lessons you can use today. Let's
rock. So you guys want to hear something
absolutely insane? Well, in the last 40
months
my YouTube grew from zero to 2.23
million subscribers. My Instagram grew
from 7,000 to 2 and 1/2 million sub-
subscribers, followers, you get the
idea. My LinkedIn went from zero to
324,000 followers. My TikTok went from
zero to 856,000
followers. My Twitter/X
the artist formerly known as Twitter, uh
went from zero to 617,000.
My Facebook, which we just started, went
from zero to 25,000. There we go. Going
in big, Facebook. Um my podcast went
from 3,000 downloads to 25 million
downloads. And my email subscribers went
from zero to 700,000
for a grand total of
2 billion impressions over that time
period and 7.8 million new subscribers.
And for a grand total of 8 million
copies sold of my book. For those of you
who are like, well, what does that mean?
And I'll get to that in a second.
So in 40-ish months, all of that
happened.
And I show all of this as proof to start
this
to show one thing is that this
actually works.
And you can build a brand
without babes, without stunts, or
kittens.
And I start this proof because lots of
people talk about stuff that they
haven't done
and teach a lot of sucky fluff as a
result. You can see the man there. He's
saying the truth. This This fluff sucks.
And I refuse to do that.
And so, before we got the 2 billion
impressions and the 7.8 million
subscribers, it wasn't like this.
Because 40 months ago, I started with
zero subscribers and a big quote fancy
plan.
And my fancy plan had three steps.
Step one, make as much good stuff as I
could. Step two, post it everywhere I
could. And step three, learn as much as
I could.
And after
40-ish months,
$4 million in team, equipment, vendors,
studios, and software,
a thousand hours of me on camera
recording,
and 35,000 pieces of content. Let me say
that again. 35,000,
as in count to a thousand and then do
that 35 times in a row.
I learned a lot of what not to do.
But I did learn six things that made
money and grew my brand that you can use
today.
Now, what I'd like to do is for the
remainder of the presentation, save you
the three and a half years and $4
million,
so you can just get the lessons without
the scars. So, that little box is our
box of six lessons. Cool?
All right. Let's rock.
So, here are the six changes that we
observed over the last four 40-ish
months that actually worked.
Number one,
going from edutainment to education.
Number two, for us to for you.
Number three, wide to narrow. Number
four, views to revenue. Number five,
shorts to longs. Number six, assume more
to assume nothing. Now, most of those I
promise you
I will explain. And if it looks like I
think I know what that means, believe
me, there's a lot more underneath of it.
So, let's start with the first one.
Edutainment to education.
So, I see content in three buckets.
On one extreme, you've got
entertainment,
which is
the entire point of entertainment, just
to define the term, is to get people to
watch. The only point of the
entertainment is to just get people to
consume it. That's it. If it
accomplishes that, it has succeeded.
On the other side, you have education.
Where the point of education is to get
someone to change what they do. Right?
If you try and teach someone how to
answer a phone, and then in the same
situation, the phone rings and they
don't do something, and then after they
watch you do something, they then change
what they do in the phone rings the
second time, they have learned. So, the
point is to change their behavior. If If
the video or the content does that, then
you've succeeded at educating them.
And lastly, you have edutainment, which
has the point of both trying to teach
and entertaining at the same time.
And to be clear, it's less that you make
entertaining content, or that you make
educational content. It's more that you
make content and people are either
entertained
or educated as a result.
And so, you can make one thing that
entertains some people,
and then that same thing educates other
people.
And so, I just want to make this very
clear that you don't control the
audience. You make something and then
education or entertainment occurs.
But for our purposes, I'll define the
content category as the most common
outcome of your content. And so, if a
lot of people are entertained, then
you've made entertaining content for the
purpose of this presentation, even if
one or two people learn something.
So, for example, some creators might
learn stuff from Mr. Beast's videos.
Wow, I learned how to make videos. But,
the vast majority of people are
entertained. They watch just to watch.
On the other hand, Walla, who's one of
the number one educators on YouTube, you
can even see the different look and
feels, and don't worry, I'm going to get
into that.
He may entertain some enthusiasts around
that subject.
But, mostly, he educates students.
And until recently, I've been trying to
figure this out. I've spent a lot of
time really working through this.
And so, I actually have videos in all
three buckets. I have entertainment
videos where the point is to get people
to watch. I have edutainment videos
where we try and teach and entertain at
the same time. And then we have
education videos where we just want to
change people's behavior. We just want
to teach them something.
And so, the first change, number one,
that we see, or lots of the data I'll
support in a second, is that I'm going
all in on education.
For three reasons.
Number one is that when we looked at all
of our data, all views are not created
equal. I'll dive into that in a second.
Number two is I like educational videos.
And number three is I like people who
like educational videos, too. And or
people who educate themselves, people
who want to learn.
And so, let me explain these.
So, all views are not created equal. So,
there's this theory, and this is going
to This will be one that's going to
rattle some cages.
There's a theory that media works like a
funnel. In fact, the vast majority of
marketing
infographics and things like that,
almost all are funnels.
And the theory goes like this.
You make entertaining content,
and then
the theory states that people who watch
that content then will go to more
educational content. Okay? Sounds simple
enough. We've got something wide, we've
got something narrow. Fantastic.
But, in our experience, in my
experience,
and based on our book sales, based on
our email opt-ins, and based on the
applications we receive at
acquisition.com to become portfolio
companies, it works much more like this.
Which is that entertainment people
want more entertainment content.
And education people want more, say it
with me, education content.
And so in other words, these people
do not become these people.
Not in any appreciable rate that we
would build a business around.
And they certainly don't read the books,
join the email list, or apply to become
portfolio businesses.
So if I want more of these people
then they deserve the stuff that they
value.
And so that's the first reason that I'm
doubling down on education. All views
are not created equal. Number two.
The next is that I simply like doing it.
All right, so you know, I do believe
that you should try and do stuff that
you like doing and if it happens to also
be in line with your goals, awesome.
It's much tougher when the thing you
like doing isn't in line with your
goals, but in this instance, when I got
that first piece of data, I was like,
thank god cuz this is stuff I like
making most. All right? And so when I
talk to ideal customers in my mind,
they're business owners and business
interested people. Because if you know
me and anybody who is who's close to me
would probably attest to this is that
like
if you hang out with me for any amount
of time, we will probably talk about
business because it's what I love
talking about. I I eat it, I sleep it, I
drink it, I work 7 days on it and like I
skip holidays for it because for me it
is the holiday.
So, this is what I like doing and this
is what the people that I like serving
also like.
And so they like it better, too.
And this is where it got confusing for
me leading up to this and why this is so
important is that it got very confusing
when you have so many people saying,
"Man, I really like the entertaining
content." And this is where it gets
difficult. This is where you have to
read between the lines of the comments
rather than just reading the comments
themselves. All right? Because the thing
is is for us, or at least for me,
they weren't necessarily who I was
trying to attract. Again, there's
nothing wrong with that. I I hey, if I
could serve the whole world, I will.
But, I know that I tend to do better
serving people who want to educate
themselves than people who just want to
watch or consume just for the sake of
it.
And so, that's why I'm doubling down on
going from edutainment some enter-
edutainment some entertainment to
education.
So, that's number one.
So, let's talk about change number two
that we saw.
Going from for us to for you. You're
like, "Well, what does that mean?" Let
me explain.
So, recently a mutual friend came to the
headquarters, and he said, "Hey, I've
been consuming your stuff for years.
But, recently I just haven't been
watching as much." And he said it
offhandedly. He wasn't like trying to
smash my ego into bits. Um and he failed
at that. Uh
>> [laughter]
>> But, when he said it, I really took it
to heart, right? It was very
gut-wrenching. He said, "It just doesn't
resonate as much." I was like, "Okay,
got it." It felt like a gut punch since
he's literally the person I could help
most. He's a business owner doing 10
million plus a year. I was like, "Man,
well, that sucks."
And that's when I realized that reading
the comments actually led me a little
bit astray.
And for you, it might be leading you
astray. And I'll give you some data to
support that.
And so, some people loved our different
styles, but not the people that I
ultimately wanted to help or am best
suited to serve.
And so, we realized that we were serving
the wrong who.
And that had some very significant
downstream impacts on what we made and
how we made it.
So, what is making for them or for
business owners content really mean? Let
me break this down into tactics. All
right, so tactically I made five things.
Number one, different packaging.
Number two, different introductions.
Number three, different meat.
Number four, different visuals. And
number five, different what I'll call
pre-work.
All right, so let's start with number
one.
So, the difference between these two
thumbnails is going from vague to clear.
All right, so if I looked at all the
stuff that we did in the past, if I
said, "What is the video on the left
about?" you probably be like, "I a rule
of some sort that might have to do with
money. Not sure."
If I said, "What's the What's the video
on the right, the yellow background
video?" If I were to describe it, I'd
probably say a map or a blueprint or
schematics of some sort that go from
zero to a million. Okay.
Well, guess what?
The one on the right is is exactly that.
The one on the left actually has nothing
to do with what that thumbnail looks
like. And what do you know? When people
click on something that they don't know
what it's about, they have a smaller
percentage of getting something they
actually want than if you say, "This is
what this is about." and then they get
exactly what they think it's about.
So, we're going from vague to clear in
both what it looks like, the thumbnails,
and what we say about it, the headlines.
And so, that's number one from a
packaging perspective that we'll be
changing and/or going more all in on.
And I want to take a pause here for a
second about this.
There was also kind of a pervasive
narrative in in the kind of marketing
world is like, "You got to have
curiosity. You got to like You don't
want to tell them everything. You want
them to to be able to get No. Like
if they want that thing, they will click
on that thing, and then you just give
them that thing.
And that has been a very hard lesson for
me to learn. And so, I share it with you
now.
So, the second is different
introductions. You guys feel on this?
Okay. Good.
Okay. Different introductions. Now, this
one is really big.
So, going from confirming the thumbnail
or confirming the headline to proof. And
this is super important. I'll explain
the difference. So, a lot of the things
that I learned, like many of you, if you
are trying to get into content creation
of any sort or media, is that you look
at the people who are who are the
biggest, right? And so, often times the
biggest people in media are
entertainers. Now, why is that? Because
everyone gets value from entertainment.
But there is no one thing from an
education perspective that can provide
value to everyone. Why? Because everyone
already knows different stuff. So, if I
educate a wide slice of people, there's
still already people who know that thing
and then do not get value. So,
entertainment by definition will always
be greater or larger the followings for
those people than people who educate.
There is no no bones about it. Like it
is that way.
And so, a lot of the lessons that
entertainment teaches,
everyone listens to because they have
the biggest followings. But, I don't
think the actual tactics they subscribe
or espouse
are correct at a tactical level. At a
principle level, yes. And so, let me
just say a second about what that
principle is.
Is that
the person who's going to consume the
content,
we want to increase their perceived
likelihood that they will get what they
clicked. So, just like the headline and
just like the thumbnails, now when they
said in entertainment, you want to
confirm it. Well, that's because most of
the sensational entertainment is
something crazy. And so, the likelihood
that someone just got the click so that
they could not do that crazy thing is
pretty high. And so, if you want people
to watch, you smash a Lamborghini, then
you better have the Lamborghini next to
you or people aren't going to believe
that you're actually going to smash it.
Now,
let's flip to entertainment for a
second. Sorry, let's slip let's switch
to education for a second.
If I say I'm going to teach you a
physics thing, I'm going to teach you
about the law of I don't even know what
the first law of physics is, but if you
push it, it will move. Something like
that. Anyways,
if I want to have proof or increase the
perceived likelihood that they're going
to be well taught, then what I actually
have to do is edify the person. Why
should I listen to you? If I'm the
viewer, there's a zillion people that
could write something on a board. But,
if you're a PhD physicist, then the
likelihood that I will listen to you and
that I will get what I want is much
higher. And so, in both of these
examples, we are actually doing the same
thing, but we do it differently if you
want to educate. And for me, when I
looked at my videos, and I'll explain
the data in a second, it became really
clear.
And so,
in entertainment, it's say the title
again, and then literally show them what
was on the thumbnail.
In education, it's show them that you
can do what you promised them in the
thumbnail, and that's the difference.
And to figure out what made intros for
our videos work, I actually rewatched my
top 35 educational videos. This actually
took some time, and so let me just save
you like a lot of hours and just give
you the nugget.
And so, I actually developed a new
moniker around how to think about
introductions for ourselves that I'm
spreading throughout my whole team, and
you can just steal it.
Proof, promise, plan.
So, I'll break down all three of these.
So,
all of the introductions of the best
education videos that we had had these
three characteristics. And I want to
make one point about the order of these
is that
you can have these three mixed in any
order you want. I would emphasize the
one that is the most important for that
particular piece of content. So, if you
have something that you're making that
you think the proof is going to be
really important, then lead with that.
If you have a promise that's incredibly
important for the audience, then lead
with that. If you have a plan that for
some reason is going to be more
emphasized, then lead with that. But, I
would say that for our content for the
most, because I'm a business educator
about making money in general,
most people have this big glaring sign
above their head before they can even
turn on the volume of their brain, which
is why should I listen to you? And so, I
tend to lead with proof.
And so, proof is that you prove that you
know what you're talking about. You give
people a reason to believe you.
The promise is to tell them what they're
going to get or learn from the video.
And the plan sets the expectations of
what will happen next.
So, let me give you a real-world example
of this.
I started this presentation with data
that shows that I've done what I'm
talking about. If I went up here and
just skipped this part,
you might be like, "Okay, all of this up
to this point, why should I listen to
you?" And you'd be right in thinking
that because you have no idea who I am.
I could just be some random dude that
looks like a Birkenstock, slightly
lumberjacky-ish, weirdly dressed man.
Like, why would you listen? And you'd be
reasonable to believe that, right? But
if you start with that, then you're
like, "Okay, well, he knows something."
The promise was what I said you would
get at the beginning. I said I learned
six things that made money and grew my
brand that you can use today. And I'm
going to save you $4 million in 3 and
1/2 years, and you'll just get all the
lessons that I learned. That was the
promise. Making sense? Okay.
And then finally, we had the plan. I
said, "How are we going to get there?
How am I going to complete that
promise?" I said, "Well, there are six
changes, and I'm going to walk through
them." That's the plan. And so, leading
with those things, we found got business
owners, or the people that I'm
interested in, to actually
better frame and perceive and get
educated on the content that we're
talking about.
And so, that's what we're changing in
our introductions.
Third, now let's talk about how this
strategy changes the meat of the
content, what we're actually like the
the real bones, the potatoes.
All right? Is that going from be real
vlog stuff, cuz we have made
that,
to list steps and stories.
When we looked at the educational
content that did the best, they had more
of the right and less of the left.
From razzle, I would I would love to say
to dazzle, but it really is it's just
razzle on the left. And so, I actually
wanted to show you different type of
content. So, I don't want to make this
seem like this is all YouTube-y. I just
have like long-form video there has all
of the elements, and some platforms
don't have all of them. So, this You
YouTube is a very easy platform to to
base this off of, but this is from
Instagram. And TikTok would function the
same way, etc. So,
if you look at the squares here, I just
pulled the last 30 days of content that
we made.
And I looked at our bottom performing
over the last 30 days that we posted
that were reals,
and then I looked at the top.
Now, interestingly,
it was a almost a a perfect reversal.
So, the bottom
12 videos that we made, eight out of 12,
I would say had more razzle emphasized.
It was more about effects, a little bit
higher production.
And on the flip side,
and this is what was crazy, and this is
why I'm sharing this stuff with you
because like I would I would literally
never have guessed it, and that's why we
look.
Nine out of 12, 75% of the best videos
we had emphasized language.
Emphasized the actual message more than
the production.
And so, it was about emphasizing the
language rather than the razzle.
I find this very fascinating. Now, to be
really clear, you can have really bad
language. You have like poor, vague,
unclear language, and it won't do well.
And you might have razzle that just
absolutely crushes. I just look at the
trends of 75% on this side were this
style or this type, and 75% that weren't
as good were this style. Well, then
let's do more of this and less of that.
And so, those are the main meat changes
that we're doing in the videos. We're
emphasizing language. This also was true
with longs as well. So, if I go and show
you this real quick, language, that's on
the screen, and that's one of our best
videos ever, and that takes up 70 80% of
the video is actually just words.
Interesting, for me at least. I mean, I
was a little offended cuz I thought I
had a, you know, good face, but
apparently no one cares. Uh
So, that's what we're changing about the
meat.
So, let's talk about visuals. This one's
a big one. All right. So, going from
overproduction, and I want to be clear,
not overproduction
overproduction for the objective. So,
it's not like we did like my team did
anything wrong or anything like that.
It's just that if we want to educate,
sometimes production distracts from the
objective of education.
If the point for entertainment is to get
someone to watch, then adding lots of
things can be a good thing. But if
you're trying to learn physics, and
there's wiz bangs and pop-ups and
changing backgrounds, it's really hard
to learn. And if that's the throughput
or that's the point of the video, then
it actually detracts rather than adds.
And so, the difference that I put in
this example here is we have a
background that changes colors while I'm
teaching something. It does not help
someone understand the subject matter
better.
Fundamentally, changing background color
will not help anyone learn more. On the
flip side, clarifying what words on a
screen are cuz maybe my handwriting's
not that good, would help people
understand.
That's the difference. So,
overproduction to effective production.
From distracting to enhancing.
From visual effects to visualizing data.
So, instead of having flames behind me,
it's What does this look like on a
chart? So, we can give relative scale.
So, we have scope, so we can show
changes over time.
And so, that's how the visuals
that did the best looked like.
And then number five,
let's talk about pre-work for a second.
So, going from post-production to
pre-search. So, instead of saying, "Hey,
let's just record something and then fix
it in post." Anybody's in the media side
knows what I'm talking about.
Four weeks of editing after, you know,
almost no prep to get a video out. Well,
what if we did four weeks of research
and then we have almost no editing
because we thought of everything ahead
of time.
Well, guess what?
The videos where we spent, I mean, we're
like the the the hour-to-hour ratio is
stupid and I'll get to that in a second.
But, if we spent a quarter of the time
that we used to spend on post in pre, we
eliminate 90%
90, maybe 95% of our post edit work and
man hours. And for the business owners
in the room, that's real cost.
That's real savings. And for the also
business owners in the room, that also
means increased production. So, if I can
take a in the quarter of the time and I
can get almost zero time on the back
end, that's four times the videos. But,
not only is it four times the output,
it's also higher quality for your goal
and your audience. So, this is a big
thing that we noticed. The videos that
we spent the most time on the front end,
we spent less time on the back and they
did better.
And so, we want to spend more time
before than after.
And so, this is my little quote on if
you want to write something down. Uh an
ounce of pre-work is worth a pound of
post.
So, that was my little my little take on
this.
And so, by focusing more on what
educates and what it means, we do great
and everything else distracts from that
goal.
And so, the those are the five things
that we're changing tactically and that
we're doubling down on to cater to
business owners. This, at least for my
audience, is what they cared about.
And I happen to be in that audience and
I feel that way, too. So, I'm happy
about it.
So, that's how we went from for us
as media people to a degree cuz I've
gotten into this now. Uh to for you or
for your audience. And for me, that
means for business owners.
So, now let's talk about why dinero. All
right, and this will also ruffle some
feathers and rattle some cages.
So, instead of talking about
relationships and college and food and
lifestyle
I'm going to be narrowing down or
doubling down on, if you will business
business models
business leverage
and selling in a business. Notice
business being in all of these videos.
In all these topics.
And so, that's how I'm going narrower.
Very simple.
Now
that I'm going to go back a slide cuz I
want to I went ahead on this for a
second.
Just like I said earlier that people who
like entertainment also just want more
entertainment, what we also found is
that people who I'll go back real quick.
People who watch relationship stuff want
more relationship stuff. And
as they should, that's what they clicked
on. That's what they want. That makes
sense. And people who want to learn
about college are people trying to make
a decision about college. Guess what
those people probably aren't? Business
owners.
And people who want to learn about food,
they watch other food videos. And people
want about lifestyle probably watch
other lifestyle videos.
But for me, those are not necessarily
the people that
vibe the most with my stuff.
And that makes sense because to be fair,
this is a little bit more foreign to me.
When I talk about business, I feel very
comfortable. When I talk about these
things,
I just give what I would consider hot
takes. This is my perspective.
So, that is what we're doubling down on
in terms of the topics that we're
choosing
for the content we make.
So, that's number three.
Let's go to number four in terms of the
the things we're doubling down on.
So, before this, we used to track views.
This is another big one. Man, all six of
these are big. Man, I'm glad I made a
presentation about it.
So, before this, we used to track views
as our primary metric. So, I'll take a
second here.
Who uses Be honest. Be honest.
Everybody's like likes don't You can't
trade likes for for paying rent. You
can't pay payroll with views. Sure.
Okay, got it.
Who here actually tracks something
besides views?
Let me say it again.
Who makes views the most important
metric you track?
All right.
Right. A lot of you. That's okay. Me,
too. But I'm going to give you a good
metric that you can track. And this is
after pouring through Believe me, I'm
I'm a big data guy. Um
a metric that you might not expect.
So, the main reason is that I had a
6-to-12-month deal cycle. So, I started
by using views because I really had no
other metric. Because for those of you
don't know what I do, well, I'll explain
in a second. But we had no idea what
what it would do besides driving
awareness. And I didn't really have any
other objective. Right? But in that time
period of doing a deal in every 6 to 12
months, because we buy companies, that's
more or less what we do, um we began
seeing a much closer correlation with
faster feedback metrics. And ideally in
any business, you want as little latency
between the metrics you track and the
behavior you want to change. And so, if
you want to get people to change
something and you want to look at
something that takes a year to get
feedback, really tough to change
behavior. But if you can have a metric
that you can see daily changes or hourly
changes, then those are things that are
going to much more quickly change
behavior so that you can have 100
feedback loops in terms of changing and
getting better than one
every year.
And so, besides book sales, opt-ins, and
applications, there was a metric that
stood out as fastest and most
measurable.
It was ad revenue.
And this is really surprising to me.
So, and I this is the point I want to
make real quick is that to be clear for
those of you don't know who I am, ad
revenue is not how I make my money. All
right, just very clearly. Um, for those
of you don't know, my wife and I exited
our first big company uh for $46.2
million in December of 2021. You can
Google it. American Pacific Group was
the private equity firm. Jim Launch
proceeds option to through those
companies. Um, and since then we
invested and bought a number of
companies that have grown a lot and do
over $200 million a year. So, I do media
to feed a lot of different things, but I
don't directly monetize the media and at
like ad revenue is
I'll explain why in a second is an
important metric that we can use for
everything else. Okay? So, these are
companies that we own. Great. So, for
me, I pretty much always ignored ad
revenue and just saw it as something
that could offset some of the cost of
the immediate team. There was really
nothing else.
But I was wrong. It's actually so much
more.
So, let's let's dive into a little bit
for a second like, how does ad revenue
come to be? So, it comes from two
things. It's number of views times
revenue per views. Now, the actual term
is RPMs, which is revenue per mill,
which is French for 1,000, but it's
number of views times the revenue that
you get. Okay, per view. Fantastic. So,
it takes into account, and this is why
this is important because we thought
views, and that was the only metric we
had, but we had to have something to
counter it cuz otherwise then you get
views for views' sake, but we needed a
quality metric with a quantity metric.
Which by the way, paired metrics, if
you're ever tracking something for a
department, having like number of
tickets resolved with rating against the
the the resolution of how well those
customer service reps resolved, paired
metrics allow you to get to the best or
most effective throughput for any
department. And I just didn't know
enough about media to find out what our
paired metric was. And this happens to
be a single metric that pairs both. And
so it takes account the quality of the
audience, which for me was business
owners who have amongst the highest
spending power. And so RPMs are the
highest. Now for So for me, the RPMs go
up, it means I'm getting more of the
quality people that I want.
And so this gave me and my team
something that we could shoot for that
balanced making videos for the right
people who wanted to watch. So I mean,
ideally, we absolutely want to crank
views with the right people.
And that's what that was able to track
for us.
And looking backwards, the month with
the highest RPMs and ad revenue also
created the most book sales, the most
opt-ins, and the most business
applications.
And this had nothing to do with how many
views we got.
In fact, we did it kind of an experiment
lately where we did 90 days of almost no
business stuff. We just did more more
edutainment and entertainment-style
content, and our views went through the
roof, like way up. Two, three X what
we're accustomed to.
But even with the increase in views, our
ad revenue dropped by half.
So we're actually getting the wrong
people.
And I share this with you so you don't
have to. Real quick, I'm going to show
you the exact 10-stage roadmap from zero
to 100 million plus that less than 1% of
companies finish I've now done multiple
times. And so I can say with a lot of
confidence that these are the stages as
headcount increases that you need to get
through. And I broke each of these down
by eight different functions of the
business, what the constraint feels
like, like what are the symptoms of it
when you're going through it, and then
what steps we actually took to graduate.
And we've done this across software,
physical products, service businesses,
brick and mortar, all of this and it
works. And it's my gift to you. It's
absolutely free. And so the link's in
the description, but you just go
acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you all free.
And so
the nice thing about this from a team
perspective for those of you do have
larger teams and want to translate this
over is that my team now has real-time
access to this. So they can see every
single piece of content and the ad
revenue that it generates and they can
quickly generate baselines in their mind
of what's good and what's bad on an
objective metric that really is good and
bad rather than just like, "Hey, this
video cranked." Yeah, but it didn't it
didn't bring any of the right people. We
got this thing that had 10 million
views. Okay, but it drove nothing.
Versus we had this video that had
whatever, 100,000 views and it made more
ad revenue than the one that had 10
million.
And we saw the corresponding increase in
the metrics that matter to us.
And so that's why we switched from views
being the metric that we're optimizing
for to ad revenue because it's a leading
performance indicator. It happens almost
in real time rather than something that
happens in a big in arrears to give you
a fancy word, later.
So that's number four in terms of the
things that we're doubling down on.
So let's talk about the fifth one.
Shorts to longs. All right, this is yet
and then another big one that's going to
ruffle some feathers.
So for a long time the prevailing idea
in content marketing was again a funnel.
It's like everything's a funnel. All
right.
And it was believed that shorts viewers
got more people to
then watch longs and then those long
viewers would then translate into
becoming customers, right? So
people watch shorts and then they watch
longs and they give you money, right?
That was kind of the prevailing thought.
But again, when we looked at the data,
it looked more like this.
Shorts viewers
watch more shorts.
And long viewers watch more longs. And
customers buy more customers.
>> [laughter]
>> And so the point is that that these are
different audiences, and I will make a
note here that
this can change my platform.
So,
I might be a long viewer on one platform
and a shorts viewer on another.
And where I do think the magic happens
is where you can have shorts in one
thing, and so someone finds you on
TikTok,
but then they are a longs viewer on
YouTube, and then they watch your longs
there.
So, I do think there's an element there,
but not the way the narrative goes.
And so for us, longs drive a lot more
conversions than shorts. Conversions
being book sales, opt-ins, and
applications, all right? And
business-related content,
unsurprisingly, brings more business
owners than not business-related
content. And so we are going to double
down on more longs about that stuff.
And change our short strategy to keep
the volume the same, but focus more on
business overall.
And again,
people watch differently on different
platforms.
So, making shorts in order for people to
on a different platform watch longs
still carries as far as we know.
So, despite the mega obsession with
shorts that has kind of prevailed for
the last few years because it was a new,
you know, format of content, we're
putting now more emphasis on longs
overall. For now,
as far as we have data.
So, that's number five.
Now, let's talk about the sixth one that
I'm going all in on.
Assume more to assume nothing.
All right, so what does this mean?
So, let's start with assume more and
what what that what that really means
broken down. So, assume more means I
made content assuming people already
knew me.
Okay?
So, here's an example.
The Alex Hormozi guide to haters. I
might be like, if I don't know who Alex
Hormozi is or I've never seen that face
before,
why do I care?
If I see the day in the life of Alex
Hormozi, yet again, I assume everyone
knows me in this. I'm I'm sharing these
mistakes with you as far as I'm
concerned for getting new people into my
world. It wasn't made, I assumed, like
everybody's going to know me.
The Alex Hormozi diet.
Everyone knows me. No, they're like, who
is this guy?
Right? And here's why this matters. If
you want your content to bring people
who don't know you, which is why many of
you guys make content,
then you can't assume they do.
And so this is what this looks like
tactically. From a headlines
perspective, if I were to remake these
today, I might try a first crack at
business influencer crushes haters and
shows how you can, too.
Okay. So now, if I'm clicking, I would
understand at least that this guy is a
business influencer of some sort, and he
crushes haters. Okay, why I might want
to see haters get crushed.
Uh day in the life of $200 million per
year CEO. Okay. Now, the jet tells this
me that this Alex Hormozi from the the
first one before Alex Hormozi's maybe
rich, or maybe he can afford a private
jet, but now I know he's a CEO, cuz I
could be a rapper. I could be, more
realistically, when I walk around in the
place that I live, all the people that
in my community assume that I'm a
football player.
It's the number one thing they're like,
"So you uh play football or you on the
hockey team?" And uh I
I say no. I can No, nothing wrong with
that, but no, that's not what I do. Um
and then, the third one there, Alex
Hormozi diet, 16-hour work day, six-pack
diet for business owners, whatever. The
point is is that we actually make it
welcoming to everyone.
And so here's how we do this tactically
within the content itself.
So, we go from they know me to
introducing yourself every time. So
earlier, I was like, "I'm Alex Hormozi,
this is what I do, this is the the the
the subscribers I've gotten, whatever."
We introduce ourselves.
Two,
they know why they should listen to me.
Tell people why they should listen to
you every time.
Three, the inside jokes. You know how I
get. No, I don't know how you get.
Please fully explain the reference,
because that references another piece of
content that I haven't seen, cuz this is
the first video I've seen from you. And
if you tell an inside joke, and someone
doesn't understand the inside joke,
guess where they are? On the outside.
And guess where people don't want to be?
On the outside. And guess where people
spend money? On the inside.
And number four, going from acting like
you're already friends to pretending
everything goes to people who have no
idea who you are.
And when you make content so people who
don't know you can enjoy it,
more do.
And for those of you who are worried,
cuz I can already hear the thoughts that
are coming up. So, let me just address
those right now. I see you.
I'm going to lose retention if I
introduce myself. Okay, well, let's play
the equal opposite. Would you rather
fewer people know who you are or more
people who have no clue?
Because on one hand, we have some people
who know you. And on the other hand, we
have lots of people who also don't know
you.
So, you're in the exact same position
you were before.
Two.
Well, aren't people going to get sick of
this? You're going to keep saying your
name every time or keep introducing
yourself? Well, from what I can tell,
warm people like the reminders and cold
people need the introduction.
And as a total side note,
this is a fun little experiment for
everyone here. You can run this when you
leave here.
If Who here actually Who here actually
has posted content in the last year?
Okay, good. Okay. Good. For a second, I
was like, this would have been really
bad if no one had raised their hand.
Fantastic. Okay.
I want you to look at last year,
and I want you to look at your number
one piece of content. And this is what I
want you to do.
Just post it again.
And then let me know how it does. And I
will bet you that it does
just as well or better than the stuff
that you're posting right now. And let
me tell you one reason why I believe
that to be true. Because if you have
been posting consistently, guess what's
also happened?
More people have entered your audience.
And guess what they haven't seen? That
amazing piece of content that everyone
from last year said was the number one
best thing you ever made. And you know
what you said? New people, you don't get
that. That was only for my old folks. My
OG's, they only get that. No, you got to
reintroduce some of the stuff, your
greatest hits. Got to bring that stuff
in so that the new people also know what
your greatest hits are. So that the lore
continues to compound and grow.
So,
number three.
And this one are sub point. And this is
one for me personally. I follow a bunch
of quote accounts. I you know, I I like
comedy and philosophy and like fighting.
Those are like kind of categories that I
follow and gym equipment.
And so I get quotes a lot on my
newsfeed. But you know what happens when
I see a quote from
Sophocles or Epictetus yet again that
reminds me that I should just toughen up
and keep going?
I like the reminder. I'm not like
Epictetus God, you lived 4,000 years ago
like get over yourself. No, he's not
making new content but guess what people
still post it and people still read it
because we need to be reminded more than
we need to be taught.
At least I do.
To give a little tactical one on this
for mainstream cuz this is what might
resonate for some of the older people in
the crowd.
There was this thing called television a
while back used to be big. Anyways,
instead of having it on your phone, it
was like this big screen on a wall. You
had a it's a whole thing. Anyways, I
won't get into it.
It's like floppy disk. Regardless,
floppy disk was okay. Anyway, so
so there used to be this thing where at
the beginning of every show there was a
theme song, right? So they'd be like
Cheers where everybody knows your name
and there's always a little
introduction. It says produced by and
all that stuff. And if those shows
that's been gazillions of dollars on
testing chose to think that despite
selling more advertising space, it was
worth having the same exact theme song
and introduction for the show, don't you
think it might be worth that for us too?
And here's an interesting thing, the
last thing. Positive associations and
six. If you actually get sing-songy
about how you introduce yourself or the
things that you relate to you, it starts
to become something that people expect
and then they start associating it with
all the positive other experiences they
had with you. So if I always introduce
something a certain way and then I
deliver value afterwards, they associate
the introduction with the value. And
guess who else do they associate that
with? You.
And so,
for those of you who are concerned, you
can add variety to this. And I want to
show you a cool little real-world
example of this.
So, The Simpsons has the
longest-standing show to my knowledge
that has existed on television.
And the introduction is the same now.
Bart would be like 70 by now or whatever
his his actual age would be if it was
actually humans. But it isn't, right?
And every introduction has Bart at some
point in detention writing something on
the board.
For those of you don't know The
Simpsons, every one of the introductions
actually changes.
>> [snorts]
>> Every one of them.
And so, they still have the introduction
that has all the positive associations
with the funny times and the humor and
the laughs that you've had with the
show.
But,
they introduce a tiny bit of variety
into them to keep it interesting. And
then what happens is people look forward
to these introductions cuz they want to
find the Easter egg. The real fans now
get catered to and the new fans don't
know about it yet, but they will. And
so, now you actually serve both sides of
the audience, the people who know you
and the people who first who are just
coming cold.
And so, that's it. Small variation, same
introduction, you let the new people in,
and you give something to the the people
who already know you.
So,
title it like they don't know you,
introduce yourself, say why they should
listen, prioritize the content that
makes sense for strangers,
deprioritizing the vlogs, the hot takes,
the opinions because
if you can serve both audiences, serve
both.
Let the new people in rather than have a
wall they have to jump over. Let them in
on the joke. Fully explain the
references that that make, make all
jokes inside jokes for everyone.
And then finally, mentally act as though
you're always talking to a stranger
because if the content does well,
you are.
At least, that's what I'm going to be
doing.
And so that's the six big changes that
we're doubling down on.
And so now that we covered those changes
in my strategy, I just want to get real
for a second.
Everything has a cost.
And it's not that other types of media
or other topics or other formats don't
work. Obviously, we had a smorgasbord.
We had a huge variety, a cornucopia,
myriad
content types
that we did over the last 40-ish months.
And obviously, we had 7.8 million
subscribers and 2 billion views during
that time period in a niche audience of
business owners. Pretty good.
And so it's not to say that other things
don't work.
I'd even say that my mess-ups also
worked to a certain a small degree. It's
just that they didn't work as well as
something else might have.
And so the game, at least as I see it in
entrepreneur entrepreneurship, is
figuring out what's my biggest bang for
buck.
Right? What's the content that gets me
the most of everything? Because you only
have limited resources. You have time,
money, energy, you put it into your
team, and that goes onto the social
media or the media that you that you
market on, and then that has output. And
so if you can become more efficient with
the inputs you get, you get more output
on the other side.
And so the question becomes, with the
resources I have, how can I maximize the
number of the right people who find out
about my stuff?
And so this is something that I live by.
Anything works better than nothing. So
raise your hand right now if you haven't
made a piece of content in 90 days.
Okay. Just do something. Because if you
do something, you will do better than
what you're currently doing.
Two.
Some things work better than others.
And three,
nothing works forever.
And so the requirement of the
entrepreneur is to start doing
something, see what works better, and
then do as much of that as they possibly
can for as long as they can until it
slows down, and then figure out what the
next thing to do is.
And then do as much as they can of that.
So, is that helpful in terms of
understanding content and media? Yes.
Awesome.
Do you feel like you got at least one
lesson without the scars saved at least
a tiny percentage of the $4 million that
I spent learning what didn't work so I
could show you these six things that do?
Okay, good.
Would you like more stuff like this?
Okay.
Well, then I've got a bunch of free
stuff that I can give you to help you
grow your brand and make some money.
That'd be all right?
Okay.
So, if you're just starting a business
right now, raise your hand.
Okay, this is for you.
I'm the co-founder of the school games.
Inside you'll find courses, full-day
trainings, the easiest business model
they know how to use this this media
stuff cuz it's one thing to just say
like, "Oh, great. I just watched this
whole thing on media. Now do I do?"
Well, this gives you somewhere to
actually practice it like a sandbox. You
can learn it, and you learn by doing.
This is one of the lowest stakes way to
make money, get your first dollar across
the finish line. And so, fun fact,
something I'm very proud of is that
right now 30.44% of people who finish
their first month make their first
dollar online by starting an online
community.
I think that's pretty cool.
And so, you can start that for free by
going to school.com/games. All right?
Tell them I sent you.
So, that's for everybody. Raise your
hand if you're
starting a business right now. Okay,
that's for you.
Now, if you're a little further along in
your business journey, I've got free
stuff for you, too. All right? Trying to
feel like Santa Claus today.
I wrote these two books right now which
have 25,000 five-star reviews and they
sold a million plus copies.
And I made courses for each of those
books that are free.
On my site, you go to
acquisition.com/training. So, if you
like this stuff, you want to learn about
offers, learn more about advertising,
learn about getting leads, paid ads,
content, all of that stuff so that you
can start making money within your
business or scale it from wherever you
are to where you want to go, I've made
this stuff for you. These are real
courses. It's not barred anywhere. You
can click there, watch them all. All
right?
See, I put that for myself because this
is how I roll. I get in the Get in the
zone. So, otherwise, you guys are all
amazing. You can go there for stuff that
will help you practice the stuff,
actually do it in the real world.
Because if you just walk away from here
today
and you do not execute anything, you
learned nothing.
And so, for the love of God, just do one
of the things so that you can get a tiny
percent of that $4 million and the
35,000 pieces of content and the 1,000
hours that I spent recording, just do
one of them so that you can take that
lesson for you. Thank you, guys.
>> [applause]
>> Now, building your personal brand can
sometimes be overwhelming. So, I want to
help you cut through the noise and give
you one more quick tactic that's helped
me grow my audience. I'm about to teach
you a rarely used method that I used to
grow my audience by 5 million people
[music] in under 24 months. And the
crazy thing is is 24 months ago, I had
less than 10,000 followers and I knew
nothing about YouTube, TikTok,
Instagram, Twitter, any of these other
platforms. And the reason that I was
able to catapult to, you know, a top 1%
creator in that 24-month period is using
this method that for some reason, no one
really talks about. Whenever I enter a
new space, whether it's trying to learn
a new skill, a new platform, a new
anything, I realize there's a massive
amount of skill deficiency that I have
to overcome as fast as humanly possible.
And so, I can either deploy time or I
can deploy money to save myself time.
So, within the world of organic content,
I was like, who can I pay to shortcut my
path to getting to where they are? So,
on one hand, I could go to like
celebrities and I did go to some of them
and they would give me their strategies,
but it was like very personalized and
tailored to them and I didn't think it
would apply to like how I run
acquisition.com in my daily life. On the
other hand, there was like the coaches,
gurus, etc. that I could go to and I
didn't want to do that because they
might be using something that worked
like 5 years ago, which honestly, I I
all the time. They're like, "Guys,
you've got to do hashtags on YouTube
videos." I'm like, "What are you talking
about? Like this that's that's not
true." And the third option, which I
ultimately went with, are advertising
agencies. [music] And what an agency is
is just a business that sells services
of advertising on your behalf. I can pay
someone to run ads for me. I can pay
someone to cut, edit, and distribute
content on my behalf. So, what I want to
do is help you decide whether or not you
should use an agency and avoid what I
call the agency trap. There's different
tiers of agencies. There's the guys who
just make [music] stuff, and then
there's the people who are real pros.
Contextually here, for one brand on one
platform, a small one might cost
three-ish, maybe 5,000 a month. The more
advanced ones are usually in the 15 to
30,000 or so a month. So, it's
significantly more money. So, here's how
I use agencies now and how you can, too.
Phase one is I get what I would consider
a basic agency. So, long before getting
into YouTube, the first step I did was I
hired a 3 to 5,000 or so a month agency,
and they just got me to commit to doing
three videos a week. They just trimmed
it, which means you take out the oohs
and ahs, put an intro, and a thumbnail.
The main objective of that first phase
was just to get the basics down, forcing
me to create content on a regular
cadence. Once I have more context,
because I've spent 3 6 months working
with them, seeing what the audience
likes, then I'm like, [music] "Okay, now
I want to learn everything." So, I go
from beginner of learning the basics and
doing the fundamentals to how do the top
creators create on this platform? No
business owner should change their
business for one client. And so, it
makes sense for both me and the small
agency, or for you and a small agency,
to part ways at some point when your
demands for what you want exceed their
capacity. So, then I work with the much
better, more advanced agency who works
with the top creators to learn all of
the more nuanced pieces of the platform.
So, rather than agree to their initial
terms, which is basically pay us as long
as humanly possible, and we hope you pay
until you die. This is exactly what I
say. Gather around.
I want to do what you do in my business,
but I don't know how. I'd like to work
with you for 6 months so I can learn how
you do it. Plus, I'll pay extra for you
to break down why you make the decisions
you do and the steps you take to make
them. Then, after I get a good idea of
how it all works, I'll start training my
team on it. And once they can do it well
enough, I'd like to change to a lower
cost consulting agreement. This way, you
can still help us if we run into
problems. Are you opposed to this? When
you start that way, I like it because
you're starting with very clear
intentions. And you're saying, "Hey, I'm
going to commit to 6 months. This is
what I want from you. And I'm also
saying I'm going to continue to pay you
after the engagement's over for a much
higher leverage, much more profitable
consulting engagement." So, that's what
a lot of agencies would ultimately want.
And if I need to pay a little bit more
than the agency fee upfront, then I'm
willing to do that. I also understand
that as I start to train my team on it
internally, there will be a period of
time where I'm paying both them and my
team. So, you're paying twice. The thing
is is that when you do that, you're
actually building the enterprise value
of your business and you're building the
asset that you own rather than being
reliant on somebody else who eventually
could, if you wanted to,
cut you off and then you'd be dead in
the water. Or, what more realistically
happens is they gouge you and they
continue to raise their price cuz they
can see how much money you're making
from the thing. With that new agency, we
ran the same play. "Hey, we want to
learn from you. We want to understand
why you're picking these things. We want
to understand the decision-making
process, etc." I start documenting what
they're doing into our processes
internally. We want to start
co-creating. So, they're making stuff
for us and we're making stuff for us.
And eventually, our stuff for us starts
to be as good and eventually better than
the stuff that they make for us. And it
should be because I'm only one client of
many to them and I'm basically renting
them as fractional labor with expertise
at a premium. Once your team has the
same amount of expertise or more, they
should be better because one, they have
more time because they're going to fully
allocate their time to you. And
secondly, because they will always have
more context on your brand than an agent
will. By having more time and more
context, all we have to fill is the gap
of expertise. And so, once we have the
expertise gap, then the in-house team
should be better than the advanced team.
And then at that point, you decouple and
you let them go. You want to make sure
that you have a clear deadline for when
you want to make that transition. And
this is good for a couple reasons. One
is cuz it sets expectations with them.
They can also see the LTV and you can
talk in terms of that. Let's say it's
$6,000 a month. I'm committing to
$36,000. All right, so like you're going
to get that from me as long as you're
not an idiot. But the real real is that
your team also knows that you're like,
"Hey, we're one month down. We got to
understand this stuff in five months.
Hey, we're two months down. We got to
understand this stuff in four months."
And so it drives you towards the outcome
of getting your team up to speed faster.
Now, you have that deadline, but what if
your team's not as good as theirs by the
time the deadline comes? Well, in my
opinion, you either need to change the
people or they're not teaching
everything that needs to happen. Because
if their low-skilled people are doing
better than your team, someone who is a
problem. Either them or you. Let's
assume that the people are right and
maybe it's just a more complex platform,
whatever. I keep going until our team
matches theirs. Once our team matches
theirs, then I drop it off. We downgrade
it to a consulting agreement just for
insurance. One or two months later, if
we feel like we're not learning anything
on the calls that we have from a
consulting perspective, we cut it. And
we do so amicably because we set that as
the expectation. That's how I grew my
YouTube. So now let's approach the same
concept but on different platform. I
didn't understand Tik Tok at all. I
didn't use it. I wasn't on it. I
actually had an agency reach out to me.
How about which is not common for me to
accept that, but they said, "Listen, you
do no work." So from a value
perspective, the offer was we You
already have enough content out there. I
can repurpose it and make shorts out of
it. And I was like, "Okay, sure. If you
want to do all the work and involve me
at nothing and just make content for me,
sounds good." And so that's what they
did. And they started getting traction
with the short videos and we're like,
"Okay, this stuff works." And then for
me, my director of brand actually had a
super deep history on short form
content. And so normally I would have
had that second phase where I would go
for that premium agency, but that
individual worked at a premium agency.
And so I actually bought the SOPs
automatically and we were able to
massively scale our output on short
content within six or so months of
working with that original agency. And
again, we're on good terms with the
person in the agency. If you set the
expectation up front, which is I want to
learn from you, and I want to be
transparent about my intentions, and I
want to eventually bring this in house
because it's my belief that my team will
be able to allocate more time to my
thing and understand my brand better.
And if they had your skills, they will
be able to do more output at higher
quality than you could ever do. You have
to make a margin, I don't. I'm going to
cover costs and get five times more
output. This is what I believe has
married the best parts of agency and the
best part of building an enterprise and
making a valuable business and avoided
the agency trap that so many people fall
into, myself included. So, the first
agency experience I ever had was
actually really good. I then worked with
like 10 more agencies, and all of them
were terrible. And this is the exact
process of what happened. So, reading
directly from 100 million dollar leads,
step one, they got me excited about all
the new leads they would bring. Step
two, I'd go through an onboarding
process that felt valuable and sometimes
was. Step three, they assigned their
best senior rep to my account. Step
four, I saw some results. Step five,
they moved my senior rep to the newest
customer. Step six, a junior rep starts
managing my account. My results suffer.
Step seven, I complain. Step eight, the
senior rep would come back once in a
while to make me feel better. Step nine,
the results still never got back to
where they were before, and I'd
eventually cancel. Step 10, I'd search
for another agency and repeat the cycle
of insanity. Step 11, for the zillionth
time, start wondering why I wasn't
getting results like the first time.
So, how do you decide if using an agency
is right for you? First off, do you have
more money or more time? If you don't
have any money, then you got to learn
it, and it's going to take time. And you
know what? That's part of life. Usually,
you master one platform, you get some
success, you get a little bit cash flow,
and then you can more quickly pay to
learn the other ones. You pay down your
ignorance assets faster. If you have the
money, then for me, it's always worth
paying down that debt. And that process
is how we approached LinkedIn, how we
approached podcasts, how we approached
paid ads, all of them. I run the same
playbook. But when it comes to building
a strong personal brand, you need to
build influence, not just have views.
So, here's how to do that. We got 32.7
million views on YouTube this month.
Here's how. So, I posted 35,000 pieces
of content this year. We did a $100
million book launch for $100 million
money models in 72 hours or 3 days. We
did over $100 million in sales. The
issue that most people struggle with is
that you're making not enough content,
number one, and the types of content
that you're making are not attracting
the types of customers you want. The
promise that I have for you today is
that I will show you a framework that I
have called SPCL, like special if you
want, but it's how to build influence
rather than how to get as many views as
possible or anything like that. All
right? But it's a four-part framework,
and I want to break down each of the
four components for you so that you can
think about how you want to approach
making content, all right, and building
a brand in general. SPCL, these are
letters, and hopefully overhead cam
works all right. So, S P C L. So, what
do these actually stand for? All right?
So, number one is status.
And this is why you hear me talk about
proof so much. But how do you define
status from an operational perspective?
For those of you who are new to the
channel, I like to operationalize
things, meaning that like I like to look
at objective reality and describe how
you would see with your eyes rather than
try and put a whole bunch of like
emotional words around stuff because
these are the like that type of language
is what confused me for a very long time
when I was coming up, and it was only
after I started defining things by what
I could see, what I could observe, did
reality feel like sharper, more crisp to
me, and my ability to predict what was
going to happen next increase by a lot.
And so, this is why I I talk in this
way. So, how do I find status? So,
status is someone who controls
reinforcers in a given environment. So,
that's a little bit fancy word, but
fundamentally, if you control the good
stuff that people want, then you will
have status no matter what it is, right?
And so, the simplest example I have is
like if you go to a bar, and it's a busy
bar, and there's a bartender, and you
have to get the bartender's attention in
order to get a drink or booze, that guy
in that moment has status. He controls a
scarce resource, right? But if that guy
walks out of the bar, no longer
controlling that scarce resource, he
does not have the same status or even
close to it, right? Like outside of the
bar, he's not getting tips every every
single 5 seconds when he like moves his
hands a little bit and like says
something nice. People aren't waving
money at him as he walks in the street.
Of course not. It's because he has
status in one condition and he doesn't
have another. Now, what's interesting
about all four of these elements I'm
going to break down, they all can work
independently, but the idea is that you
want all four to be stacked together.
And this is what gives you the most
influence, right? So, like any of these
four on their own would give you
influence. Like that bartender, if he
just has that, he would have some level
of influence. And I'll give you a
different example of this. If a kid
inherits money, right? They're going to
have uh status, right? Like if you just
if you have money, even if you didn't
earn it, even if you didn't anything, if
you have money, you will have some
degree of status because you control
something other people want, period.
That's how it works, all right? But,
would that kid who has money have the
same status as a kid who has money who
also gave you, you know, 10 different
crypto coin picks that all popped off,
right? Well, if he gave you 10 different
picks and you followed them and they all
popped off, how much more influence
would that person have over them saying,
"Hey, you should put money in this." or
"Hey, you should, you know, give me
money for XYZ." or whatever it is.
Obviously, I'm talking money cuz I'm I'm
a business person first, but like think
about how much more influence version
two would have with just two of those
things versus version one. That's the
difference. But, if you have all four,
that's when you get you become super
sad. So, status is number one, so you
control scarce resources. Power is
number two. I would say if I had to only
pick one, I would pick power and I'll
explain why.
Power comes from something in the
behavioral dynamics world called say-do
correspondence. What that means is if I
say something and then you do it and
then a good thing occurs, a reinforcing
event happens afterwards, you are more
likely to comply with a following
request, right? So, said differently,
I give you the example of the guy who
says, "Hey, here's 10 stock picks, you
buy them." and then a good thing
happens. The thing goes up. Great. So,
that person has status and power, which
is why they are more influential than
the trust fund kid who just has money.
And so, to the same degree, for many of
you who are trying to make content, one
is like, okay, status, I want to
demonstrate that I control a scarce
resource that some people might want,
right?
And so, what makes this a little bit
more muddy is that sometimes one event
can check multiple boxes. And so, I'll
give you a simple example. When we
launched the book, we did 100 million
plus in sales. That in and of itself, me
having money from the event gives me
status. Me saying, "Hey, you can launch
stuff in this way." gives me
credibility, right? Because I show that
I have an event I've something that has
happened as a result of me doing it that
gives me third-party credibility.
There's something that you can observe
with your eyes, right? The reason that
my ads do well when I have my, you know,
$10 million building behind me is like,
"Oh, well, that's hard to fake, right?"
And so, you have credibility there. And
so, one event like selling a company can
give you money, it can give you
credibility, and then if I give people
directions on how they can do things
that are similar, and then good things
happen, then all of a sudden you get
power. And then the last is likeness. I
know I'm skipping around, but hey, we're
live. We're having a good time. All
right? And so, credibility is number
three.
And I'm going to go into more detail on
all of these. All right? And then
likeness.
So, what's likeness? So, likeness is
that you see some This is some people
say relatability. This can be both
psychological in terms of you share
similar values with this person. You
like you like their vibe, whatever you
want to say, right? You like their
behavior set and it and that behavior
set matches to people who have been
positive in your life in the past or
they literally just look like you,
right? So, like Leila and I could talk
about the exact same stuff, but she's a
girl and so, she's going to have more
chicks who follow her than me. And for
the few ladies who do follow me, I
appreciate you. I really do.
But I have like an 89% male audience.
And so, maybe it's it's because of the
topic, but I would think, you know, at
my onset I think, "Oh, it's because I
talk about money and I talk about
business, that's why I have a more male
audience." But Leila I think is like 54%
female. And she talks about almost
exclusively money and business.
Obviously, she talks about some mindset
stuff, too. But I I say this to say,
"Okay, if we have these four things and
these are the things that create
influence." And I I define influence as
high likelihood of compliance with
requests. So, what does that mean? So,
if I say, "Hey, you know, grab my new
book." Or I say, "Hey, come to this
webinar." Or "Hey, I'm going live. Like,
come check it out." Or "Hey, you should
come to workshop." Whatever it is,
right? You make some sort of
solicitation. It could be like or
subscribe. It doesn't matter. Like,
there's levels of how cool big of an ask
something is. If anybody's played like a
video game, it's like you have like a
roll for like Dungeons and Dragons. And
it like depends on how how charismatic,
how much influence you have, how high of
a roll or how low of a roll, rather,
you'd need in order to be successful
with the request, right? And so, if you
want to stack that stat for you, then if
you want to min-max your influence, if
you will, then you want to stack all
four of these things. Okay, you're like,
"Okay, I think I'm I'm following with
this." So, how does this relate to
content? So, first off, starting from
the back, likeness,
I think so much more of it is just like
just be you. There's zero ROI in trying
to be or act in a way that is different
than who you are. It's It's a relatively
trite message, but like most people are
NPCs. Most people say pre-recorded
scripts. They look at like the four
different outfit, you know, combinations
that exist for different kind of mental
stereotypes. It's like, "Oh, yeah, guy
who loves barbecue and craft beers. Oh,
yeah, that's that That's that archetype.
I'm just going to be that archetype." Or
you've got like hipster bro who likes
hipster right? Or you've got
you know, like just bro, right? You've
got who just like stir bro. And people
Some will put me in that status, but I
also like for a few years was wearing
like sandals that looked like really
weird. And I wore those, and that was
not bro-y at all, but I like I wore them
because they were super comfortable, and
I didn't have to like wear socks, which
is a big thing for me. Anyways. But
point is just like I think what makes
you unique if is if you actually lean
into the the nuances that make you you
and actually have a way to defend why
you do what you do. Because most people
don't even think about why they do what
they do. And if you do things and you
don't know why, it's not It's because
you're following someone else's
directions for your life, rather than
your own.
Real. Like, real. And so, so much of us
have been programmed by people earlier
in our lives. And I say programmed as
though we were like machines, but what
person do you think in your life has
super high max status, power,
credibility, and likeness? Maxed out
earlier on in your life. It's your
parents.
Right? It's your parents. So, think
about all four of these elements.
Status. Do your parents control scarce
resources, things you want? They've got
money, and they've got toys that they
can buy you, they've got food, they act
like they control your shelter. Like
they have huge amounts of status in your
life cuz they control all the scarcest
resources, all the things you want.
These are not binaries. So, don't think
like, oh, I have status, I don't have
status. It's to what degree do you have
status? Right? Like if somebody's got
more money than you, they might have
some status. If you've got $1, and
someone's got 10 grand, they got more
status than you, right? But if someone's
a billionaire, they have way more status
than the guy who's 10,000, right? So,
again, think not in binaries, yes or no,
but think in continuums. So, the next
one is, think about your parents. Power.
How many reinforcement cycles do you
assume that your parents had from the
time you were born? When I say
reinforcement cycles, it means like they
said, do this, you did that thing, and
then a good thing happened. Now, you
might be like, ah, I hate my dad, I hate
my mom, or whatever your thing is. I
don't really care. That doesn't matter
for this purpose. The idea is that they
probably said, don't go in the street,
or don't do that, and you avoided a bad
thing, or do this, and then a good thing
happened, right? You tied your shoes the
first time, you put the two bunny ears
together, you tied your shoes, a good
thing happened, they you followed their
directions. Think about how many times a
parent has given you directions, you
followed them, and a bad thing was
avoided, or a good thing happened. Many.
And so, it makes sense that not only do
they have a lot of status, they have a
lot of power. What else do they have?
Credibility. Now, this is one where I
think parents sometimes might lack
compared to the other things. If you
have a parent who also has credibility
in that specific, you know, realm of
whatever it is that they're talking
about, then you would have even more
influence on you. And then finally, for
parent,
are they like you?
Yeah, they literally look like you,
right? And oftentimes, they share
similar values to you, to a degree.
Obviously, some people just go polar
opposite from their parents. That's
fine, but I'm talking in sweeping
generalities for most people. This
should at least explain or break down
like why do parents have so much power
over us? How much How do they have so
much influence over our behaviors? You
might not even want to listen to your
parents. You might not even like your
parents, but you can still feel that
they you have to like resist their
requests because you are so programmed
based on these elements of behavior to
comply with their requests, right? And
so then the idea is how do we take these
four elements, and then how do we
reverse engineer these into the content
that we have so that we can build up
true influence? Like and again, we're
defining influence as the likelihood of
a compliance with the request, right?
And that likelihood will depend on the
nature of the request and how much your
SPCL is in relation to that thing,
right? If I was giving out fashion tips,
I probably don't have a lot of
credibility
>> [laughter]
>> for fashion tips, right? I don't know if
I control any scarce resources around
fashion. I have no I have no fashion
hookups. Um I probably haven't given
anyone specific fashion tips. I have no
third-party anything for credibility for
it, and you probably don't look like me.
>> [laughter]
>> And so like I probably would have very
low influence. To some degree they can
generalize as you go up and up and up,
but um you have more influence in domain
specificity. If we know these are the
four things, status, power, credibility,
likeness,
then for each of these things in our
videos, right? We want to demonstrate
that we control scarce resources. And so
for me, like at the very beginning, if
you think about what the intro was,
right? So I said, "We did, you know,
32.7 million views,
and we did over 100, you know,
5.something million dollars in sales for
the book launch in 72 hours." And so
that's me demonstrating status. I have
these things, right? Then
power. So what I'm going to do in this
video is I'm going to break down four
things you can follow, and if you follow
these things, you're going to be more
likely to get people who are going to
comply with your future requests. And so
that means that they're not just going
to watch your video, but they're going
to be more likely to one, watch your
next video, and if you have any kind of
call to action in the video, whatever
level of call to action that is for you,
whether it's subscribe or like or share
or or, you know, buy something that's
small or, you know, set up a call or
whatever it is that you sell, then this
is going to be second, right? Like
that you'll have included that in your
content. So then, credibility is going
to be the third-party stuff. So the
reason that I had at my launch, for
example, I had Guinness, I had to pay
those judges to be on site was because I
wanted to validate that the the the
books that we did and the revenue that
we generated was legit, right? So I had
a a third party that most people
respect as like a legitimate corporation
that their entire business is based on
trust that they validate and verify
proof that these records were broken.
And so that gives credibility. The
likeness piece, like I said earlier, is
just you being you, right? And so that's
why I'm actually super pumped to do
these live streams cuz this is like I
honestly hate making YouTube videos.
What I mean that is like staring at a
camera and having like, you know,
prompts to, you know, solicit me to say
stuff. Like I will do it because I have
a relatively high pain tolerance and
I'll do what is required to get what I
want, but like I'm I'm going all in on
this. So if you guys are like, "What's
Alex's kind of like media strategy for
the future?"
I'm I'm I'm focusing on two words. You
can write this down. Live
interactive. [music]
Those are the two things that's that is
describing the ACQ 3.0 or Mosey Media
3.0 vision for what's going forward.
Like that is what I'm focusing on. And
I'll tell you a story of why why I think
this is so interesting. So I had a
conversation with a a mega influencer. I
don't think he would mind
with Mr. Beast a few weeks ago, and we
were talking about kind of like the
future of media and content. One of the
things that he was talking about was
the soccer game that came up that they
do like UK versus US. What ends up
happening is that they have all these
different celebrities or influencers
from different platforms, right? And so
starting from the lowest, the lowest
people on this little totem pole, they
would walk out in the stadium and this
became the kind of the de de facto like
measuring stick for who had who had the
most cool points, right? These are the
A-listers. And so, this is your typical
kind of celebs from like movies and like
'90s and the 2000s or whatever, right?
People like they recognize cuz they're
celebs, but like they don't have like
huge I guess they have some media
presence, but it's more like traditional
media. The level of applause for these
guys was almost nothing. Barely anyone
cared.
>> [music]
>> So, then the next level that came up was
the shorts, the shorts creators. So,
this is your like only TikTokers or
people who only make Reels, but like
only short videos. And so, they had a
little bit more applause on the
applause-o-meter
compared to the A-listers.
>> [music]
>> Then the long-form guys came out. And
this is when the audience got way
rowdier. All right, so this is your
podcasters, your YouTubers, the people
who make long-form pieces of content.
And I'm going to pause here for a second
to kind of like highlight why I think
this is. I don't think there's anything
wrong with shorts. We make tons of
shorts. But, I see the purpose of shorts
as many times a way to get someone to
watch a long, right? They watch a couple
a couple shorts and then think, "Okay,
this guy seems legit or this gal seems
legit. I'm going to risk my time." cuz
that's the risk, they're making an
investment, right? You're making an
investment today. "I will risk that we
get a good return on this, right?" And
so, shorts then lead to longs. But, let
me show you the difference from an
influence perspective. How many
reinforcing cycles do you think you can
have in 30 seconds compared to 2 hours?
It's like not even close. And so, if
someone watched two 1-hour pieces of
content for me, period, okay? Two 1-hour
pieces, that's 120 minutes. For me to
get that same level of exposure and kind
of cycles of reinforcement with a
prospect, and they were only consuming
shorts, right? Let's say my average
short, let's say it's 15 seconds. So,
that means it's four shorts per minute.
So, if I have 120 minutes for longs, I
have to do Someone would have to watch
shorts to have the same level of
exposure as watching 2 hours with me.
And think about how how important this
is. What were the things that people
said, like this was the quote podcast
election. Trump went on and I don't care
about the politics behind it, but I do
care about influence and persuasion. And
so like why is it that the two podcasts
that I think really nudged this
election, my opinion, is the Trump
three-hour plus podcast that he did with
Rogan like a week or whatever it was. I
think that was a huge influential event.
I think Elon getting on uh Tucker Tucker
Carlson and doing that interview. I
think those two interviews were some of
the interviews that really nudged the
election. And again, I don't care who
you voted for, it doesn't matter to me.
I think about this from marketing
persuasion, okay? And so because of that
audiences who were not sure got to spend
three hours with a presidential
candidate and as a result, it just
nudged some of them in the direction to
ultimately vote, okay? Now, back to our
little story. A-listers have almost no
applause, shorts have slight applause,
longs have legit applause. Then
>> [music]
>> the live streamers.
When the live streamers came out, it was
like the entire auditorium or stadium or
arena erupted.
And when I heard that, it was such a
visual example of I mean we have this
saying which is like butts and seats. If
you just make a bunch of like meme
content, right? You demonstrate almost
none of these things. Some of you guys
are chasing views when what I think you
want is you want to have prospects who
are more likely to comply with a future
request. And so we need to change our
behavior to maximize the likelihood that
occurs. And so in in looking at this
thing, this is why I'm I'm telling you
like showing my cards, I'm going to be
doing more live streams. And I think
it's also and this is me like outside of
SPCL, but I think like meta themes
overall, I think that the internet will
always move towards truth. And so I
think the A-listers everything's super
curated, everything's super polished,
it's photoshopped, it's scripted. And as
you move closer this way, it's raw-er.
Like you have a three-hour podcast, like
if they're not scripted, right? Or most
of them aren't, right?
Um streaming it's like, yeah, we're
live, right? I can't do anything, like
we're live. This idea of of how can we
approximate the rawest reality of you us
hanging out, right? And actually going
through this stuff, I think that is what
will unlock the most influence as long
as you are still including these SPCL
elements into it. And I think that's the
marriage. Do SPCL and do it as many
times as I possibly can. That's the
idea. And so live streaming provides
that that opportunity. Let's also think
about this from a context of volume.
Whether you like him or not, Rogan,
tremendous influence, right? To the same
degree, PBD, tremendous influence. Uh
Dave Ramsey, tremendous influence. What
is it that these guys have in common?
They're putting out hours of content
every single day. So, I said it earlier
that we 35,000 pieces of content, right?
I hear plenty of times there's tons of,
you know, $1 million businesses, $2
million businesses, things like that.
They put out one piece of content a day,
right? And there's nothing wrong with
that. That's 360 uh 65 pieces of content
a year.
And if you think about the size of
acquisition.com in terms of our revenue,
right? Compared to somebody who's doing
one or two million dollars a year and
they're doing 365 pieces of content,
we're just quite literally doing a
hundred times more. And as a result of
that hundred times the volume, what do
you think's happening?
We get a hundred times the prospects.
And so people want to try and like
outsmart themselves in thinking that
they can like not do the work that's
required, but it's actually far more
linear than you would expect. So, like
we just know that like one out of ten,
you know, shorts is going to go, you
know, is going to be a two or three X
outlier. We just know what that math
looks like. Same thing for longs. How do
I just jam as much into that
input-output machine as I possibly can?
And as long as I'm checking these boxes,
like I'm making the right kind of
content, then you're going to get the
right kind of prospects. So, I'll give
you one more nugget, like I said,
which is that some of you guys may have
heard this, and it's a concept of
social media
is now turning into interest media.
[music] Okay? So, what does this mean?
Let's unpack this for a second. If you
make content and you judge it by views,
I think that's dumb and I'll explain
why. If I have a grandma public come and
just do a running slap and just slaps me
across the face, that video will
probably get views. But, does it get the
grandma views? No. Does it get me any
any more people who now believe more in
my stuff? No.
But, what it will do is it will show it
to people who are interested in humor,
which is a lot of people, right? But,
those might not be your customers and
they probably aren't. So, assuming
you're not an entertainer and you are
somebody who's a business person. If you
sell services to anyone, you're likely
going to be an educator, not an
entertainer. Meaning you're you're
you're trying to provide value to people
to change their behavior in some way and
ideally change their behavior that gets
them to walk closer to you and buy
stuff. Okay? So, what do I mean by
social versus interest? If you want to
attract the right avatar, make content
for that avatar. That sounds so obvious
and simple and the thing is that no one
does it because here's the writer
downer. The content is the targeting.
The algorithm is so good now, it knows
what you're talking about it. It knows
it can it can literally judge your your
background. It judges what you're
wearing. It judges who you are and will
display it to the people that they know
have a history of watching content that
is similar to that, that people find
valuable. And so, if you are making
stuff about how to fix pianos because
you're a piano repair guy, then you will
find people who are trying to fix their
pianos. But, if you're making that type
of content, you might be like, "Man, I'm
only getting, you know, a thousand views
a video." It's like, "Yeah, but the
market of people who are buying pianos
might be significantly smaller than the
market of people who just want to be
entertained or distracted." So, you it's
not fair to to compare your views
against Mr. Beast. It doesn't make any
sense. If I were to think to myself
like, "I have a room of a thousand
people that are going to watch this and
all of them are only interested in
fixing pianos, that's a hell of an
opportunity." I care so much more about
IRL responses. So, what I mean by that?
If I make a video and then I get texts
from business owners that I like and
that I respect being like, "Yo, that was
fire." Then, I'm like, "Okay, I'm on the
right track." And so, some of you guys,
let me know in the comments you guys
have seen
um a format that we talked about. We
call it cash cows. But basically, it's
me, there's a business owner that
presents a little bit about their
business, and they come to this side,
and we talk about how to like how to
improve their business, right? So, let
me know in the comments if you like that
style. And if you do, let me know if
you're a business owner or not. Okay?
So, uh like I like that style, and I'm
not a business owner. I like that style,
and I am a business owner. Or I don't
like that style and I'm a business
owner. Or I don't like that style and
I'm not a business owner. If you are a
business owner, when I have people who
are here in person, IRL, in real life,
in Vegas, right? Business owners who fly
out. I ask, I say, "What is your
favorite type of content?" Dollars to
donuts, that's their favorite type of
content. And so, I make more of that.
Even though, and it would make sense.
Like, it would make sense that there's
fewer of those people. Right? Just think
about math. If you've got uh
if you've got the whole population here,
let me I'll I'll I'll I'll show you a
little graph on this. So, let's say that
100% of people, like this represents
100% uh let's just use USA cuz I already
know all the numbers for USA. Okay? So,
let's say this is 100%. All right? You
get 100% of people who are interested.
Okay. Well, right now, only 9% of people
even own a business.
Like, 9%. So, right off the bat, I'm
going to have a huge percentage of
people that aren't my ideal audience.
Now, of course, I do have people who are
business interested, and that's why I'm
a co-founder of School, and we give
people, you know, a way to go uh start a
business online in a in in a low-cost
way, right? Which you can do. It's nine
bucks a month after a 14-day trial. You
guys can check it out. And there's a
bunch of like training and community and
all that good stuff. All right? But, you
can go school.com, I think {forward
slash} Hormozi. I think it's below this
video. Doesn't matter. Point being, 9%
is what I'm competing for. Okay? Now,
that means there's there's about 32 to
33 million uh business owners in the US.
Okay? 32 million. That's that's 100% of
all business owners. Now, within that,
95% of that 9%
is below $1 million
in revenue.
95%.
Then I've got 5% of that 9%
that are over a million.
Now, if you want to get If you want to
get weird with it, what percent do you
think is over 10 million?
.4%
1 in 250. And then a hundred million,
nine figures, is I think one in roughly
3,000, depending on like your data
source. One in 3,000 businesses gets to
100 million a year.
This big.
And so it would make sense then that
we're given these numbers, right? 9% is
is 32 million. So I know 5% of that is
going to be a million and a half people.
There's only a million and a half people
who are business owners doing over a
million, based on the math that they
that that This is Census Bureau data.
Maybe theirs isn't correct, but that's
the math, right? And so if we're looking
at that's the market, then it would make
sense that I'm not going to get all 100%
of them to watch my video, right? If I
got 1 and 1/2 million views and 100% of
them were business owners, I'd be
insane, right? And so it would make
sense that like if I get 100,000 views
on a video that has that's really made
for that level business owner, then I'm
crushing it, right? And it doesn't make
sense to look at, you know, Mr. Beast's
video with 100 million views and be
like, "Oh man, I suck." It's like,
"Dude, we're we're going after We have
different We have different games,
right?" And so I'd encourage you to
create accurate expectations of the size
of the market that you're going after
and also think about the translation of
these numbers into IRL. I have two
businesses that I looked at in the last
year that were doing over a million
dollars a year with less than 5,000
followers. You absolutely can make
plenty of money with a very small
following as long as you make content
that's directly valuable for that
following. All right. With that being
said, uh we just went over
SPCAL, status, power, credibility, and
likeness, what you want to include in
videos, why I'm going all in on live
streaming, and why the whole point is
you want to get as much time with your
uh prospects as humanly possible. You
want to make the topics of your content
based on the things that those people
find interesting, not uh based on like
being social, but being interesting. If
you get If you make it interesting for
them, they will keep watching it. And
then, being realistic about your
expectations on how many views you can
get based on your size of market. So,
let's say you've built a personal brand,
here's how I would monetize an audience
to make more money. In my second
company, Prestige Labs, I built up to
over 5,000 affiliates that generated 20
plus million dollars a year in revenue,
and that business continues to this day.
In Allen, my software company, which is
my third big company, we built up to
over 1,000 affiliates that were agencies
white labeling that software. For my
book launch for 100 million dollar
leads, we got 30,000 affiliates who
promoted the actual book launch. I've
also invested in companies that I've
personally endorsed, and so I bring all
these things up because most people
don't know how to quote monetize an
audience.
And after talking to a lot of creators
or celebrities and influencers, and also
business owners who want to do deals
with those people,
a lot of people don't share a construct
in terms of thinking through how to make
those deals happen. And so, I wanted to
make this video to outline the four ways
that I see those deals happening and the
combinations between them and what
considerations you might have, whether
you're on the doing the deal side of
having an audience or
being the person who wants to quote buy,
license, rent the audience from an
influencer or somebody who has those
eyeballs. All right? So,
four ways to monetize an audience.
Let's use a good marker
that doesn't suck.
Step one,
have good markers. Four ways
to
monetize
an
audience.
All right?
Now,
right off the bat,
number one, we've got affiliates, which
is what I was saying earlier.
The second way that you can monetize an
audience is through sponsorships. Some
people call these endorsements.
The third way that you can do this is
through partnerships,
which usually involve equity.
And the fourth way that we can do this
is through starting your own, if you're
the influencer in this instance.
All right. So,
we have affiliates, which is where you
are getting paid after you make sales
for a business, sponsorships where they
pay you first to advertise on behalf of
the business, and typically endorse it
via your brand,
partnerships where you go into a
business that already has a product,
already has an infrastructure, and you
do one of these two things or a
combination of these two things
for equity. And so, the behaviors
between affiliates, sponsorships, and
partnerships are more or less the same.
The difference is simply how you get
compensated. And then the fourth is
where you just start your entirely own
brand to then promote to your audience.
All right? So, let's break down which of
these and kind of where they sit on the
continuum. And the reason I want to
bring this up is because I'm having so
many conversations with people who are
like, "I have this audience. I've built
it for 4 years. I just don't know what
to do." And so, I think of these four on
a continuum.
All right?
And I can think of this continuum in
terms of difficulty and risk and value.
All right? And so, on this side,
you've got the affiliates. This is the
fastest way that you could immediately
make money. Most businesses that have
affiliate programs, you can sign up
automatically. They have predetermined
terms that are associated with this
agreement. And as unless you do
something that's really, you know,
nefarious or weird, they're happy to
have you sell their stuff.
So, one is this one's fastest. This is
low risk for kind of both parties
because
if you're an affiliate and you're
promoting it like they don't have to pay
you until after you make a sale. Now for
you, you also don't get capped. And so
if you can make a ton of sales and you
feel like you're being under valued,
then you just get to prove that you are
actually good at promoting and that your
audience is actually a good fit for
whatever that product is.
But from a value perspective, so I'll
call it exit value
affiliate revenue streams are not
typically that valuable. So they will
contribute to the sellability of a
company, but the majority of that value
would come in the terms of a multiple of
the cash flow that you're receiving as
an affiliate
multiplied or discounted by how reliable
the business that you're doing business
with is. And so if I'm an affiliate of
the US government you know what I mean?
And I recruit people for the military,
then I probably can say that my business
model is sound and the US government's
not going to go away.
I'm not getting not not withstanding,
you know, theories and whatnot. All
right, but by and large it's going to be
a trustworthy third party.
On the flip side, if I have some you
know, info thing that is going to
disappear tomorrow because of some
arbitrage opportunity that's your
business opportunity, then this is going
to be
basically have no value because that
business that underlines that cash flow
has no value. All right, and so we're
moving along here. So this is the lowest
value, probably middle work, lowish risk
for you. All right, the next is you've
got sponsorships.
So sponsorships is where someone pays
you first. All right, so you receive
cash and then you make the endorsement.
And so usually this is in two forms. You
advertise to your audience
and the reason I say advertise rather
than here it sell, here you only get
paid after people buy. With
sponsorships, you get paid first. And so
that means that you are advertising. You
are a traffic source for the business.
And so you will get paid as a traffic
source, typically based on CPMs, meaning
cost per thousand impressions that you
can have in terms of views to an
audience. Now, these sponsorships come
in the form of you posting stuff to your
audience, which for them they see this
as free traffic. They're technically
paying for it, but you're monetizing the
traffic that you have. The other way,
which is the more scalable way, is
something called white-listing.
Which is basically them taking whatever
your posts are and then running them as
ads. And so, let's say I have a million
person audience, I make a post and only,
you know, 200,000 people see it. And as
most content creators would do, you
wouldn't want to post over and over
again about that thing cuz it would kind
of be like, "Oh, this guy's just
promoting this thing over and over
again." It wouldn't feel good, right?
And so, you might make a post or two
every so often to not interrupt the
value that you're providing to your
audience too much. And so, the way to
solve this really for both parties is
you make an advertisement saying, "Hey,
I just partnered with so-and-so. Their
thing is awesome. I've actually been
using it for years. Finally came to an
agreement. I think you guys might like
it. Check it out, right?" And so, that
white-listing then allows them to blast
it to people way outside of your
audience. I like this a lot as a win-win
because the business
pays money to advertise your brand. So,
they make you bigger and they're
spending money to advertise you. But at
the same time, they get higher
conversion rate because you're probably
better on camera, you're better spoken,
and you already have a certain amount of
warm audience that recognize you, at
least your face or your mannerisms. So,
you convert at a higher percentage. So,
the business makes money, you grow your
brand. This is a really nice
partnership. Now, these deals,
sponsorships, are harder to come by than
affiliate deals because most affiliate
companies just have a program, an
influencer program, an affiliate
program, and you just sign up on the
standard terms. Sponsorships tend to be
more a la carte depending on the size of
the influencer relative to the size of
the company. And so, for extreme
examples, if you're a huge influencer
and there's a tiny company, you'll be
able to get an amazing sponsorship deal.
If it's a huge company like Nike and
you're a small influencer, you might not
get any deal and you still wear their
stuff. And so, it's really the balance
between who has
how much leverage in the negotiation.
Which brings us to the fourth one. Or
sorry, the third one, which is
partnerships. All right? Now, as we move
along here,
sponsorships
also don't have kind of like affiliates
huge exit value. The only place that
sponsorships really become exitable
valuable exitable value for a business
is if you have a true media company.
Now, if you're a personal brand, it's
really tough to exit your personal
brand. But if I have an army of
influencers and I negotiate deals
through my network and say, "Hey, uh you
know, Pabst Blue Ribbon or, you know,
Budweiser, whatever, I have a thousand
influencers that fit your ideal profile
for customers and I'll negotiate an
umbrella deal and then all of them are
forced because they have with them to
promote your stuff. Now, you have a
media company, which is very similar to
a talent agency, slightly different, but
has a lot of similarities. And so, then
then that sponsorship revenue is really
the main revenue of your business, which
is that you sell traffic at a discount,
right?
But for the
uh for the influencer individually,
these two things very hard to sell.
Not really sellable. Not much.
Now, once we get into this side, these
deals get harder and harder to do and
you do fewer and fewer of them as you go
down this line.
So, a partnership can either be a
minority deal
or a majority deal. Again, if you're
going to go partner with a company and
you're huge and they're tiny, then it
might be a majority deal. If they're
huge and you're tiny relative to them,
then it might be a minority deal,
meaning you're not going to get all of
the company. And that
can range from, you know, 0.01%
of the business all the way to you
getting, you know, 99% of the business
in terms of the range. And so, anything
that you can imagine in terms of
economics here is going to be
negotiable. But, one of the thing or
some of the things that I would consider
here is performance, which is
This is again for both parties.
You can have equity as the form of
compensation rather than necessarily
cash. And you say, "Hey, if I bring you
an extra thousand customers, I get, you
know, 1% per thousand customers that I
bring you to the platform or whatever."
And then you put a cap on that at some
point where you say up to
to, you know, 10%.
Great. And so that way it's a little bit
balanced for you and for the business.
Now, one of the considerations that you
have to have if you were the uh content
creator or the influencer is that the
the
the association that you make with their
brand is permanent. As soon as you make
that public declaration, you transfer
all of that goodwill, you transfer that
association to them. And so if you are
going to do a deal like this, my
recommendation is that you want to have
at least something up front.
So no matter what for doing this deal,
you get some amount of this equity up
front and then some percentage that's
based on performance. Now, the
one of the last components that I'll
say, and there's obviously a lot of ways
that you can do deals, but these are
just the things that I think through,
is time. And so somebody who's on the
business owner side is like, "Well, I
don't want you to just make one
association. I want you to keep doing
this for a long period of time." And so
they can take some of this equity that
they want to give you and say, "All
right, I'm going to give you, you know,
25% of your equity up front. I'm going
to give you
uh 25% based on performance and I'm
going to give you 50% over time. And so
I want you to promote for the next four
years. And if for some reason something
happens, then you're not going to get
that vesting
because we had some sort of breakup,
right? And so whenever I think through
these terms, I just like to think of
through all the W's, which is who, what,
where, when, why, how, right? Which is,
"Okay, I want you to post." And if
you're the content creator, you should
be asking that same thing, which is
"How much do you want me to post?"
Right? And about what? And you have to
take into consideration that you have to
keep building your brand, right? And so,
you don't want to just be like all of a
sudden some shill. Like, that's not
good. You want to tastefully be able to
integrate that promotion into the
content that you have. And so, you'd
have to say, "Okay, well, I think the
best way for us to do this is for me to,
you know, put uh your links in my bio,
and I'll put it up for 1 week of the
month, and I will make one long-form
thing that it mentions it, and you know,
five short-form things via posts or
stories." And then when you define that
reason this is so important is that you
define that stuff up front so that it's
just very clear. Don't just say like, "I
will promote the business and whatnot."
cuz it just doesn't work as well. And
you might say, "I will also, you know,
record ads once a month that you can
then use for whitelisting." And so, all
of these things, and this is where this
gets more nuanced in deal making,
is you can be a partner and still have
affiliate revenue. You can be a partner
and still get paid from a sponsorship
perspective. And so, these things are
not mutually exclusive. But, like, you
might have a primarily sponsorship deal
with some element of equity. But, I will
say on a personal level, the more money
you have right now, the more you want to
lean this way because
the equity
the sponsorship cash that you choose to
take, you do it at the expense of
equity. And if you believe in the
product and you believe that the company
is exitable in the future, then it in my
opinion, it makes sense to delay it for
the little bit longer run. But, this
takes on more risk because here you get
paid today no matter what. Here, you
might not ever get paid if the company
doesn't sell. And so, by taking on more
risk, you want to make sure that you're
getting a disproportionate reward in the
in the form of stock shares, options,
equity, and things like that. All right?
And so, as we're walking through this
and you're thinking, "Okay, how can I
monetize my brand?" It's like, "Okay,
the first level, I can do affiliates and
just promote other people's stuff and
get paid for it."
The next level, I can be a media source
for them. I can be traffic for them via
sponsorship, right? These are a little
bit more nuanced deals.
Taking another step, I can actually
partner with the brand and say, "Hey, I
want to own 1%, 5%, 10%, 50% depending
on how big you are and how big your
audience is. And then finally,
you can start your
own
brand.
And when I say brand, I say that
all-inclusive in terms of products and
brand. And when you do this, you can
either
white label,
which means you go to somebody who
manufactures stuff already and say, "Can
you slap my logo on it?" which is an
option. And the other option is that you
do custom formulations.
Custom I'll just say custom stuff. All
right. And so, if I were selling
supplements, for example, I might go to
a a company that already has a product
that's done and I just say, "Hey, I want
to slap my label on it." On the custom
version of this, it's like, "Hey, I want
this gram of this. We're going to test
out flavors together and then we're
going to put it together and make a
custom product that no one else has."
Same things works with merchandise. So,
if you said, "Hey, I want to get a white
t-shirt." and you just try six different
white t-shirts that people have off the
shelf that are manufacturers, they say,
"Okay, just slap my logo on it and let's
go." or you say, "Hey, what are the
different fabrics? What are the
different materials that I can put
together? These are the cuts that I want
to look at. This is how I want it to
fit." right? That becomes more custom.
And so, white label is faster and
easier from a speed perspective, but
usually, me personally, I prefer to do
custom stuff because I don't like anyone
else being able to sell something that's
identical to me and be able to have any
kind of pricing power over what I have
cuz it the moment that people find out
that you just have a generic product
that you slapped a label on, it just
does It's not a good look. Right? And
so, again, I don't think there's
anything to Like, I want to be clear. I
don't think there's anything wrong with
doing white label. I just think that if
we were to put this on this sphere, like
white label would be here and custom
would be here. But, if you're going to
take the risk on of starting your own
brand, I might as well get all the
benefits of doing it. But,
this costs more money. White label tends
to cost less because you don't have to
get custom templates, custom forms, and
pay and incur all those costs cuz
someone else their whole business is
based around doing this for other
people. All right? Now, the difference
here is that for all of these
situations, you're going to promote
stuff that already exists. Here, you're
starting the thing from ground zero,
which means that you're on the other
side of the table now. You start with
100% equity,
and then you start paying people this
way down the line. And so, if you are an
influencer, you have an audience, or
you're a business owner and you're
trying to make deals with influencers,
this is how I think through this, and I
try and see there are elements that you
can borrow from each of these kind of
verticals to
tweak the deal to make it right for
everyone. And so, I think about it in
terms of what's the exit value,
what cash is going to be going in or out
of the business, how much work is the
person going to do, and then how much
risk am I or are they exposed to. And by
balancing those four things, you can
usually navigate along this continuum to
find the right part the right deal
that's right for you and the product. As
a bonus, I want to take you behind
scenes to what I just learned with my
personal brand so you can make more
money and grow your business. I made
35,000 posts over 40 months and grew a
7.8 million person audience, and 3 weeks
ago, I made six big shifts in my
content, and I want to show you behind
the scenes what we found from those six
big shifts with screenshots of the data
so that you can use this to make more
money in your business and whatever you
promote. And so, the first was we went
from edutainment to education. So,
instead of being kind of halfway through
to all the way all in on education. Now,
that had downstream impacts in terms of
how we package, how we title things,
even the number of special effects we
have, and the purpose of education as I
see it is to change behavior. And so, my
point is with this video, once I show
you the data of what's happened since
that change, since the we made these six
shifts, that hopefully or hopefully not,
we'll see what you decide to do, but it
will change how you make content to make
more money. So, number one is we educate
edutainment to education. Number two is
we went from for us to for you. Now,
when I say for us, what ended up
happening with the mistakes I made was
that I mean, unknowingly, was that I'd
be like, "Team, what do you guys think
about content?" And so, they'd be like,
"Hey, we should make a video on this.
Hey, we should make a video on this."
And so, what ended up happening is I
started making videos for my team, not
my ideal customer, a business owner. And
so, I actually had a friend come into
town and say, "Hey, you know, it's
weird. I actually haven't been paying
attention to your content." He does
about 10 million bucks a year. And uh I
was like, he's like, "Well, I guess I'm
not really your avatar." And I was like,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa." I was like, "You are
100% my avatar. What's going on?" And
so, as soon as I realized that, I was
like, "Oh, man." He's like, "It just
didn't feel as relevant to me." And so,
I was making stuff for my team rather
than my avatar. And so, if you are
somebody who makes content, something to
be mindful of is
your team might not be the type of
people you're trying to make content
for. So, just something interesting for
me. So, we went from for us, our team,
to for you, viewer, for business owners.
Number three was went from wide to
narrow. So, fitness, relationships, etc.
These are wider topics. More people are
in relationships, more people eat food,
more people trying to lose weight,
compared to only 9% of people are
business owners. And so, we went much
narrower on the topic of like, "I'm just
talking about business cuz that's what I
love talking about too." As a side note.
And so, it turns out business owners
like it more when I talk about business,
and I like it more as a business owner.
So, everybody wins, at least for me.
Number four is we went from views to
revenue. Now, this is key. So, when you
just have views as a metric, then you
kind of do chase wider because it was
the only real metric we were tracking.
And we didn't really have anything
better at the time and since we focused
on. Since then, we transitioned to ad
revenue, and here's why. Ad revenue
takes into account views, but it has a
second metric that's paired with it,
which is RPMs, which is revenue per uh
thousand eyeballs. So,
if you if YouTube pays lots of money for
the eyeball, then it means they're more
valuable. And if they're more valuable
to advertiser, they're more valuable to
me. And so, my idea here is that I want
to make sure that we're showing our
videos to the right people, or rather
that the right people are watching. Now,
once we can control for that and we stay
or keep our RPMs, or the amount that
advertisers are willing to pay for these
eyeballs, high, then we get as many
views as we can. And as a total pro tip
for business stuff in general, paired
KPIs works exceptionally well. So, if
you're in customer success, you want the
speed of resolution, but you also want a
quality metric. If you had a a company
that did cleaning, it'd be the same
thing is you'd pair reviews from
customers with the number of cleans per
day. And so, you like to have both edges
so that you can control for both sides.
And you should do that with any
department you can. Now, so I said
number four was views to ad revenue as
our primary metric that we were
optimizing for. So, we no longer care to
oh, this one had a lot of views. We
don't care about that. It's just do we
have as many views with the right
people?
Number five is we went from emphasizing
shorts to emphasizing longs. We saw that
longs got the best people, and short the
whole thesis around shorts creates longs
viewers, we actually haven't seen any
evidence that supports that. People
watch shorts want more shorts, people
want longs want to watch longs, which
doesn't necessarily mean that people
from a different platform
don't watch you on shorts on TikTok, and
then they're a long-form YouTube
watcher, and then watch your stuff on
YouTube that long. But usually, people
who watch long-form stuff on YouTube
watch long-form stuff on YouTube. People
who watch them on YouTube watch
short-form. Some people watch both, but
most of the time people are kind of have
consumption preferences, and they're not
going to change the preferences for you.
They just might watch you in a different
place where that consumption preference
is what you make. And so, we found that,
and we found that the longs are the
things that actually drove the most
applications for acquisition.com, and
the most book sales, and the most
opt-ins. So, that's what we're making
more of. And number six was assuming
more versus assuming nothing. Meaning, I
made videos like the Alex Hormozi diet,
I made
uh the the Alex Hormozi vlog, the
Hormozis, things like that. Those assume
that somebody who doesn't know me
will want to care what whoever the hell
Alex Hormozi is, which I don't think is
that reasonable. Like, I don't think
they would want that, cuz who cares
about this random dude? And so, it's
assuming nothing. Now, that has
um changes in terms of what we're
making, so there's no assumptions. So,
for example, like we're on
acquisition.com, we have portfolio
businesses, I introduce myself because
if you don't know who I am, this might
be the first video you see of me. And
so,
if I stopped doing that for a while cuz
I kind of wondered this mindset that
every everyone knew. Now, obviously
that's dumb. Way more people don't know
me than know me. But, you kind of fall
into this trap of assuming you're
talking to your warm audience rather
than what you're making the content for,
which is people who've never met you
before. And so, keeping that top of
mind, which is that we want to make sure
that we welcome everyone and that we
don't have inside jokes that only people
who are on the inside feel it because
then all it does is it excludes people
that are new. And like what you want to
do is bring more people into your world
anyways, especially if they're business
owners for me. And so, there are these
six changes that we made in our content.
And so, we've gone all in on that
concept. And so, we've done a lot of
rapid iteration. But, let me tell you
the data that's happened since. So,
right off the bat, RPMs, meaning the
revenue per thousand viewers, went up by
68%.
So, like when you think, man, I don't
feel like I can like what my content is
about, like it doesn't change anything.
Well, it sure as hell did for us. When I
talk about deep business stuff, when I
talk about reducing churn, when I talk
about increasing number of time like
ways to get someone to buy more times,
when I talk about how we scale a
40-person sales team and the all the
steps that we did in order to do that in
a real case study in a real business,
when I talk about how you can
deconstruct and reconstruct a brand,
these are deeper business concepts. And
guess what? Business owners watch them.
And guess what? Those eyeballs are more
valuable. 68% and we're only going to
get better at it. And so, for us, boom,
that meant that us changing our topics
got the right people to watch the
videos. Check box one. And so, you can
see by the video title when we had
educational versus kind of wide or
business education versus wider topics,
the wider topics in general had way
lower RPMs. You can see that with the
the light blue. Whereas, the purple
is more money making, more business,
more sales, more more, you know,
retention, real business tactics that
grow companies. And those,
unsurprisingly,
were way higher in average RPM. Some of
them even higher than that. So, the next
big change, and I see this as anecdotal,
is that 25% more comments per view. And
so, I see that as an engagement metric
that we had way more people saying,
"Wow, this is good." or "This is great."
or "I miss this style of content." And
that's actually a really common thing.
And I will say this, this is to my this
is to my detriment. I should have seen
that more business owners were telling
us in the comments what they wanted. And
honestly, I just wasn't listening. Um
and that's on me. I I was like, "Well,
you're going to lose some people as you
make more, you know, high-production
stuff. That's okay." But with the return
to hardcore business education in terms
of the content that we're making, the
response has been overwhelming. That so
many people were like, "I'm coming back
to all your content. This has been
great. This is what I came here for."
And so, I'm stoked about that. And so,
we got 25% more people who are uh doing
that. We have more shares, negligible,
and slightly fewer likes, which again
whatever. But for me, I would say
comment I would rate comments and shares
as higher. And so, overall, we had
higher engagement from these videos,
even though they were narrower topics.
Which to me is
more good for fewer people than a little
bit of good for a lot of people, which
is where I want to be in terms of what I
want to serve or who I want to serve.
So, the next big change is that despite,
and this is a key point, despite having
fewer absolute views per long-form
video, we're actually getting more
long-form views overall across the
channel. So, we're up 30 almost 30%
29.56%
um than our our 6-weeks average before
that
from these deeper educational videos.
Now, realistically, that's a function of
one main thing in my opinion.
That's because
the education stuff actually requires
far less post-editing. And I can make
more education stuff cuz this is what I
do every day. And so, we can actually
create more content, which I'm stoked
about, and I think I think I mean,
hopefully business owners are too. Um
and so, we actually get more overall
views with the right people because we
don't have nearly as much high-fi
post-production wiz-bangs, which is what
most of my audience who is trying to
learn stuff rather than be entertained
was happy about. All right, this next
one is very surprising to me at least.
So, our subscriber conversion increased
by 24.6%.
And so, that means that we've actually
like even though again we had slightly
lower lower absolute views, more
long-form views, that we actually
increased the absolute number of
subscribers per week since doing this.
So, like I mean, I was very comfortable
with all of these metrics tanking. Like
that was I honestly expected that
because I was like, all right, we're
going to have way fewer views, but it's
going to be the right people. But,
because 25% more people who watch
subscribe even though we get fewer
views, our actual subscriber growth has
grown.
Which is crazy in an absolute metric
way. So, this was this was an unexpected
outcome for me and has just reinforced
that this was the right decision for the
audience that I want, which is business
owners. The next thing is like, okay,
well, if you're getting fewer views,
how's that going to translate to opt-ins
cuz I'm a business owner. Like that's
what I care about. I care about people
who are trying to
to become portfolio companies, come to a
workshop, whatever. And so, it turns out
that we have 26%
more opt-ins per week since making this
change. And so, this is like both
incredibly surprising and also
incredibly duh. And I say this because
like saying, "Hey, I'm going to make
business owner stuff to get more
business owners." Duh. But at the same
time, I'll say this, just me kind of
commenting on a lot of the educators
that are in the space, they tend to
start moving more and more broad, more
and more wide, more and more
entertainment-y, more and more topics
that they don't necessarily have
expertise on because they seek the
views. Whether they say it or not, they
don't want to sit there like like saying
cash, cuz they still kind of count their
likes. And so,
I think if you can just absolutely get
your logic head on, which is tough
because sometimes you it's it's tough to
to go away from those vanity metrics.
But, I care about the bottom line and
so, the right people were seeing it and
the right people were taking action. And
so we, in the in the business sense, saw
growth from this in a big way, and this
is just like 3 weeks in, 4 weeks into
this kind of execution all in on the
strategy, and this will compound. And so
for those who don't know, I have two
best-selling books on Amazon. They're
still like number one and number two on
marketing and sales, and they've been
there for like number one and number two
for 2 years or 3 years or whatever how
they've been out, so they're pretty
strong. And so we sell books every month
no matter what. But what was crazy to me
was to see this jump in book sales that
happened as like think about this, we're
getting fewer views,
but
more sales by a lot, like 2x the sales,
twice, not like 20%, twice the sales of
books that I have. And mind you, by the
way, if you're like, "Hey, I'm poor." I
get it. My books are free, too. They're
by like you can go to akuz.com and you
get the video course, all my stuff for
free. You don't have to opt in. And you
can go on my podcast, and you can listen
to the audiobook for free, all right?
Like the stuff's free. This isn't how I
make my money. But it's a really good
leading indicator for me of the quality
of traffic. Now, if you want to get a
physical copy, yes, there's printing
costs and there's shipping costs, so
yeah, you pay some bucks. But if you're
dead broke poor, you can use the free
stuff. The point is is that this
attracted the right people, people who
want cuz if I make a fitness meals
video, guess what those people don't
care about? Getting leads and making
offers. Kind of sounds obvious when you
think about it. When I make a, "Hey,
this is how I work with Layla, my wife,"
maybe you get somebody who's like, "What
about the married entrepreneurs?" It's
like, "Well, only 9% of people are
business owners, and then of that 9%,
how many of them are married to their
partner?" Percentage of percentage.
Versus just talking about business
stuff,
business people want to get more leads,
make more offers, make more money. And
so that's what my books are about. And
so lo and behold, more of those people
bought.
Now, I want to be super clear. I want to
show these two these two keynotes here.
So
there There some keynotes that will be
both deep and wide. And as a content
creator / business owner
/ investor /
husband / human being
boy big um sometimes you hit it out of
the park and you actually get both. So,
my highest revenue revenue per view
video also happens to be
my most viewed video.
And so, it doesn't necessarily mean that
if you have a lot of views, the RPMs are
low. No, not at all.
You can get a video that applies to all
business owners and it will get a lot of
views.
And the CPMs or the RPMs will be high.
The branding video is the same thing.
That one's that's very recent. It's new
and it continues to climb up. Um and
they're both of these are very
conceptual business concepts that all
business owners can benefit from. And
so, if I talk about leverage, almost all
businesses need to understand strategy
and leverage. It applies It's a huge
amount of value to business owners.
Understanding brand, tremendous value to
any business.
Now, on the other hand, you can also
make and we have we call these keynotes,
but like longer form either whiteboard
presentations or like a presentation
that I put a lot of time into. Um some
of them are going to be deeper and less
wide and that's okay. Like, if I talk
about scaling a 40-person sales team, if
you have an e-commerce store, doesn't
affect you. But, leverage and brand
would affect you whether you had the
40-person sales team or the e-commerce
company or a software company or an app
or whatever. And so, again, the scaling
40-person sales team still super
valuable, but it's just going to be only
you know, valuable to 1/3 of the
business owner audience that I might be
able to you know, who might want to
watch this. Same thing with um
same thing with the video I made about
10Xing your business overnight by using
mega influencers. Basically, showing how
to get a Mr. Beast, a Logan Paul, a Rock
to partner with a Conor McGregor, a Huda
Beauty, a Taylor Swift to partner with
to 10X your business. Now, if your
business like a local business, the
likelihood that they're going to partner
with you is really low, right? And so,
it doesn't really make sense for that
particular business. Now, you could use
that on a micro scale, but it might just
not have as much transference. If you
have an e-commerce brand that's
national, might make a ton of sense. But
again, it's going to have a sub-segment
of already a 9% slice of the population
that it would be deeply valuable to
though. And so, that's the thing is is
that I have to think about like I'm okay
with a video that gets 10,000 views
instead of 400,000 views. If 10,000 of
those people are $10 million plus
business owners, it's like here, here's
how I packaged my company in order to
sell it. I have a video on my channel
that walks through 46 minutes of the
decision-making process I used to
determine to sell my business. Guess who
that applies to? Basically no one,
unless you're actually have a lot of
money and you already have a business
asset that is $5 million profit or more.
And so, let's see, 9% of businesses it's
like
0.1% do $10 million a year
of businesses. So, there's like no one
who that actually applies to except for
those people or like this thing was
amazing and this changed my life. And I
had a bunch of people after I posted
that that I know that were big 20, 30,
40 million dollar a year business owners
who watched it be like this is insane. I
can't believe you gave this out. I'm
like, believe it because guess what? No
one else is going to watch it. And so, I
will say this, this is me giving you
like a little hat tip for consuming. If
you're a business owner
I would not gauge views as whether the
whether the video is good or not. It
just shows how relevant it is to how
many people.
And so, if you're an e-commerce person,
I have some videos in here about how to
use offers for e-commerce.
That's just already going to be a slice
of a slice, but it'd be super applicable
for you. And so, I'm okay with very
small views as long as the quality gives
value and provides a result in a clear
way for the viewer.
And so, I define education as change of
behavior. So, if I can help them change
the behavior in a way that makes them
more money, ideally they'll associate
that money they made, that value they
made with us at acquisition.com.
And so, that's the whole goal of this
stuff. And for the creators out there,
or those of you guys who are making
content in order to promote your
business, I'll give you this frame that
I started out with that helped me a lot,
which is
you know, when I first posted my first
like I started at zero on every
platform, to be very clear here. Like it
wasn't like I was Taylor Swift and I
came on TikTok. Yay, right? It wasn't
like that.
When I started on YouTube, I had no
subscribers. And the first videos I
posted got like 100 views, right? But I
thought to myself, I was like, man, if I
like I would probably go across town to
speak to a 100-person audience for
lunch, and I'd have no problem with
that. And so, the idea that I had 100
people, I was like, that's not bad. Or
even if there's 10 people, I'm like,
well, I would talk to a 10-person I
mean, I used to do this for years. I
would do a lunch and learn and uh see if
I could sell some weight loss. You know
what I mean? Like I was willing to do
that anyways. And so, there's this it's
it's literally just because of
comparison that people feel bad about
their social media content, not because
inherently the numbers don't make sense.
And the crazy thing about this, and I'm
going to re-emphasize, is it's free.
It's free. The platforms distribute your
content for free. These are people that
would never found out about you and they
find out about you for free.
Like take that in for a second. So, the
leverage on free distribution is
infinite. And so, if you get 1,000
people over a month who see your thing,
it's 1,000 people. It's not nothing.
And so, I try to make sure that I focus
on that concept of like, oh man, my
average for the channel is 400,000 and
we got a 50,000 view video. 50,000? My
god, I speak at conferences with 1,000
people. It's 50 times that.
Not bad. And those people I got to have
a really, really curated experience,
increase the value per second,
absolutely crush as much value as I
possibly could in that in time period.
And so, I'll make one last note on uh on
the deep versus wide content, is that I
get so many DMs and like Slack messages
even from our portfolio company founders
who are like, dude, that last video was
so sick." And I hadn't had that in a
minute for probably the the 6 months we
went a little bit wider with our
content.
And it became so reinforcing for me.
Even though like what's the what's the
number of people? I don't know. 50
people maybe messaged me being like,
"Dude, that new like your new content
style or going back like the new old
content of more whiteboard, more deep
business tactics, like it's so great. My
team's watching again." That like fills
me up cuz that's why I made the stuff to
begin with was the stuff that I didn't
have when I was coming up that I wish
someone would have taught me. And then I
had to just find out through trial and
error. And so that's why we make this
stuff.
But
the views weren't high. But for me like
I'm here for business owners. And I
already know there's only 9% of people
are business owners.
And that's okay.
I'm for you I'm here for you guys. All
right. So here's what we're doing next
with this data. All right. So we had our
hypothesis. We looked at the 35,000
posts. We made the six big shifts. And
by and large we have crushed the
hypothesis. So I'm actually like I was
telling my team yesterday I was like
we're kind of lucky that this worked out
the first time cuz like I'm not really
used to things working out the first
time. I'm more more like realistically
be like, "Hey, we made this change and
then like four of the six stats are bad
and two of them are good." And so we're
like, "All right. Well, these ones are
good. So let's try and keep this stuff
the same and then we got to tweak all
these other things."
Our view to subscriber ratio is higher.
Our absolute subscribers are higher. Our
options are higher. Book sales are
higher. Applications are higher.
And it's about stuff I like making. So
I'm like I'm thrilled to tears. I'm
stoked. And I get to make this stuff
about like we can do more content
because I don't have to put as much post
into it for you guys. So like you guys
said it's more distracting to have the
whiz bangs and the effects. And we're
like, "Cool.
I'm happy to just talk business." So
this is what we're doing now.
So one big belief we have is volume
negates luck. That's in the sales team
locker room. Same thing in the media
team. They said, "We will we will create
more. And we will just basically have
constraints on where like the direction
of what we're creating, but we will keep
we will keep making as much as we can in
different ways to find out what works
even better than our first whack at it.
The second thing is don't get the same
scar twice. We're super happy to make
mistakes. I mean
I I It's funny. I even I I I almost mean
that. Like it's totally fine making
mistakes cuz like they're not mistakes.
They're just lessons. What we don't want
is get the same scar twice.
And so if we find out or we know that I
have to introduce myself
then I better keep introducing myself.
If we know that high high five
production doesn't do as well with
business owners
then I better not do that. Right? Unless
there's a conclusion that we find that's
wrong about that. But for now
like that's what we're not going to make
the same mistake twice. And so I'm happy
to make all the mistakes there are in a
very narrow field. That's what makes an
expert.
Um but I just don't want to make it
twice. A third one, this is super
tactical, is that uh
slides versus just me heavily prepping
for a presentation hasn't made as much
of a difference. So I tried to
approximate this by like my best videos
that were most views and most business
centric in terms of CPMs was me
presenting at a conference. So I have a
stage in my headquarters. And so I was
like, "All right, I'm going to present
on my stage." But it was to it was not
to an empty room. It was to my to my
team. But like a lot of comments were
like, "Is this guy pretending to be on
stage?" And so if you did see that,
that's why it was uh that's why the the
the room was kind of empty. Um but I was
like I was trying to approximate as much
of that style of video. So that gives
you maybe a little bit insight. I was
like, "Okay, well what can I control? I
can do a stage. We can do the lighting.
We can have the seats. I can have
slides." These are all things that I'm
used to doing. Now it worked to a
degree, but we got the same performance
from me just talking to a camera like
this and going over the slides without
the stage or me just doing whiteboard of
walking through the concepts or the
tactics to grow or solve a problem.
Number four.
Show what only you can show and say what
only you can say. And so I have I have a
few marketingisms that I have never
heard anywhere else that are like very
real for me. One is state the facts and
tell the truth. It's always that way cuz
then you never get in trouble, you don't
have to worry about anything, you don't
have to worry about claims, you just
state the facts and tell the truth.
Which also means that you have to go
collect data so you can state the truth.
Um and so a second one underneath of
that is say what only we can say and
show what only we can show. It's
demonstration, right? And so
if obviously I have accomplishments that
I can say, "Hey, I know what I'm talking
about." But there's also labor. And so I
can say, "Hey, I built uh 8 million
person audience."
Listen to this stuff for content, which
by the way, you don't have to listen to
any of it. This just worked for me.
Um or I can say I made 35,000 posts
independent of the outcome. And so what
I want to do is do more work than anyone
else will do so that I can show what no
one else can show and say what no one
else can say. And so if you're starting
out or you're you're you're a different
part in your journey, considering like,
"Okay, well, I can't out-outcome anyone
yet cuz I'm early, but you can outwork
people."
And so I can't just say like, "I made
35,000 posts. What I learned."
I'm going to compress a lot of time for
you. That's valuable, no matter who you
are. And number five is still doing wide
shorts. So this is interesting. So
we thought about this and we decided
that for shorts we're willing to go a
little bit wider. And I'll tell you why.
So I run ads
and Leila runs ads using our face. And I
actually see the main ROI from shorts as
top of funnel brand awareness. And when
I say brand awareness, I really just
mean like facial recognition. People
will see my face and remember that they
got some sort of value from it.
And in a short it's more difficult to
get into really deep business concepts,
which is what I'm
um not saying it's impossible and maybe
I just need to up my skills, which is
totally totally fine. Um but we're still
maintaining a certain percentage of
shorts that I would consider to be more
like um a little bit wider. Because I
tend to like business philosophy, too,
and I don't want to stop. Like, what are
the things I like talking about? Like
philosophy. I like wide business
concepts. I like personal development
and sort of in terms of like
productivity, which is kind of kind of a
wider topic. But I'm not going to stop
doing that cuz I do like making that
stuff. And so,
I'll probably keep having shorts around
that because the ROI is actually not
from shorts turning into book sales or
shorts turning into opt-ins. It's
actually the shorts
getting retargeted later with an ad that
does go to something, but they're going
to be more likely to recognize me and
then take the next step in whatever it
whatever the funnel is. Whether we're
saying, "Hey, if you're starting a
business, go check out School." Which by
the way, again, wide.
If someone's trying to start a business,
then it makes sense for it to be a
little bit wider for people who are
trying to get into it. And so then the
School ads can hit those people and it
makes sense for them to use School,
right?
Uh if it's
a business owner, I still think that
from a business perspective, we have a
lot of business content in terms of our
shorts. But I want to just address this
in case you see it, so you're not
confused about it. I still will have
some wide content in short form
um
because of the reason I just said. And
so, those are the kind of like the next
steps. And if you guys find these kind
of updates valuable with the metrics
behind it, um the TLDR of this whole
video is that
what we said worked.
And if you're an educator,
toss out the views, focus on your
customer, make stuff for them because
likes ain't cash, views ain't cash, cash
is cash. And so if you're trying to grow
your business, make sure you're making
the stuff for the people you actually
want to make, not your ego.